this week on the true Jodi podcast the
biggest-selling male artist in British
music history and his name is Robbie
Williams I've spent the whole summer
with you guys literally on tour every
podcast that's come out I've watched
beginning to end I'm a huge fan
[Music]
got something Italia and she said I've
got something to tell you and I'm like
oh you first but she said you're in that
band you could find yourself going down
a rabbit lava pletely
and it's a lot of fun but if you mix
that with marijuana myosin whatever I've
got that drove me to be the person I am
is an unrelenting monster that doesn't
know when enough sin on
let's just say my life became in danger
right and it wasn't safe for me to be I
mean I'd love to say I'd love to say no
I can't I didn't know I don't know how a
month I don't know what's gonna get you
ya know but I used to sleep with a gun
let's put it that way right and it's
like guns name it was called desi Eagle
I have an ism and alcoholism and
addiction but also my own special ISM
that makes me want to isolate that makes
me want to keep away from people you
know it's like I don't want to be him
why not what I don't want to I don't
want to be the Hermetic yeah isolator
yeah because I like people there's like
if I get miffed or if I go upset or if I
feel as though you put me down I just I
want to kill you and whereas before I
was trying anything because I was
experimenting all of a sudden you sort
of life I've got to find a hit from
somewhere and I never thought like that
your song of your career comes angels
massive massive songs the biggest song
someone simply wrote that
[Music]
you got to think of the cash cows or
Chennai mean who buys the tickets
everyone by the tickets I'll be watching
the menopausal people now yeah even then
are we in are we going so menopausal
women love them
yeah officially yeah love them mums with
the menopause partly you get some cream
that really helps with those women if
you want to have them it's my favorite
category on youporn menopause for mums
with cream so yeah yeah it's good places
not mental nuts so actually this is a
wedge these big black dicks we'd last
that is my favorite yeah but baby C's
yeah yeah baby DS yeah if you want watch
porn you don't want to watch something
where it's sort of half job but you
don't mean you want to see that the
backdoors being broken and on your own
yeah you sort of you get straight into
the faketaxi
mm-hmm do you know the fake tax oh you
know what's that well we're hoping to
get him on after you generally made the
Lycian way up keep going up in the world
yep fake touchy I wouldn't if he's got a
nice house like this he's doing really
really well I mean there's lots of
content
he's a Content King on YouTube right now
there's a bit of an issue people written
stuff off where's he's found that
Nisshin he's nailed it down in a way
actually quite literally now I said this
is a very - to normal isn't it um I
think me and Robbie feel a bit more
normal than you judging by your fear so
it's your birthday I do it's my birthday
yeah yeah hurtling towards 30 minute Oh
we spoke about this yeah how old are you
okay just turn so when you were 29 how
did you feel
saying and when you were 30 didn't care
I feel better cuz I'm richer than when I
was 29 sorry can I give you two both a
second because I can tell you one look
at each other and work out what the
other one looks like in real life taking
each other's face in you're both going
yeah no no we add that we we had a chat
because you were late coming down the
day so we we did the podcast we were
quite I feel as though we've we've got
repartee between each other a good hug
yeah it was a good rug and we now find
in each other you haven't had the chance
but we do that well the thing is what a
lot of people won't know because I like
how the Fox Joey got Robbie Williams on
the podcast I'm on a train in about
August September time and I get an email
off one of the people who work with you
saying my client would like to talk to
you I'm like [__] another time waster
it's all I need tell them tell them
their messages on facebook that he'll
Joe sugg to message me on Facebook
though she's like no it doesn't use
Facebook doesn't use
what kind of loser she's like Robbie
Williams oh all right then
no no original reaction was probably
isn't really but I did think was
absolute bollocks may I send a picture
of something I think no said follow us
on Twitter if it's because you're
talking [__] always thinking business in
business is is that I've spent the whole
summer with you guys literally on tour
if every podcast that's come out and
watch beginning to end I'm a huge fan so
it's it's like it's just a mutual like
you know the television swirl their
computer screens come to life yeah so
and obviously you know I've sold a few
records so you know me so there's like
the same like Lawrence wanted to be you
especially when he was you know like
right when you were younger you really
want so this is a bit I told Robbie only
the first single of what was rock DJ and
I played that even though the Chateau is
embarrassing story yeah yeah I was a bit
of a showy kid
really yeah only child obviously and
when rock DJ came out to see you
stripped down in the video yeah so I
gathered my family in the living room
and when I'm gonna perform Robbie
Williams rock DJ little did they know I
was gonna strip down partly because of
the video show yeah so where did you
channel you're showing us then where did
because just celebrities that I looked
up to at the time yeah no but when you
you were you going to be like we've jazz
Hansy were you going to be an actor or a
singer or actor an actor want to be done
you know what happened you see how he's
flipping it he's the other vo yeah we've
got a long time so I yeah I've got I've
got questions too great with ya gone so
I was on the stage as a kid I not like
in London but aim Burton I was huge and
burn I did a town hall listen I'm the
amateur operatic society in
stoke-on-trent has never had a finer
actor than me since I left there you go
you know i unsee that videos of them
doing Oliver Twist jeez you've been
doing your EP doing you read this but
that's 24 hours watching Robbie Williams
documentaries loose women interviews
very insightful let me go just go back
so so you're at school you were sure we
kid you remember are you doing local
amateur operation society and Lee School
of Speech and Drama it's still there is
that why your Scouse accent is rounded
off no no I don't know if I mentioned
this on the podcast before but my dad
was a teacher in the school and so
mentioned it few times yeah and he used
to get kids from the school to come and
like babysit me right and one night when
we first moved down these two girls came
over and babysat me and as I was reading
them the book that I had set as homework
from school they were laughing and they
were like why did you talk like that I
was like I'm just the way I talk now
like Oh
and then I cut that out from their own
saucer so embarrassed about it
the scab spit orden talking like a baby
there's cows bit oh the baby bit I
retain no you're at school doing me on
me you're doing you're at school you're
doing local amateur operatic stuff
you're go into Lee Lee Lee and Lee
School of Speech okay and so that's
where you gonna do why did you let your
dreams die I found radio okay yes no
well no I listen to her FM at the time
you were huge on that yeah they love
that second rinse you yeah and I used to
record the songs off the radio and then
play them back to my mum and be like
here's a song for you mom here's a song
for so you did your own radio show in
your own house I used to record the
adverts off the radio and then I had to
take that so so then you went into
proper radio yep and what was that
Hospital radio we're at but Phoenix
Hospital radio and we use rises from the
flames okay yeah holy people get well
yes that what it is
exactly yeah that should be the emblem
the only people get well and I've told
this story on the podcast before but
originally I tried to get rid of us cuz
I didn't really like us because we were
young and boys and we did the talking
yeah did you ever get into trouble was
there anything that you ever said that
was sort of near the knuckle we upset a
few people in the first few weeks and
then they tried to get rid of us and
then I came back and they didn't like
when we played the game where we guessed
what the job of the person was based on
that god
oh really annoyed them the nurses got
upset okay okay so you're a hospital
radio it's the start of the podcast I'm
asking the questions for a little bit
okay I do move do it over the phone
okay Brian's got a life as well so you
then went from Hospital radio to where
Sheffield where I did community radio
okay trained did you start getting paid
they've had my travel did they pay you
at the hospital no no we used to just
get a lift from my dad and then my
friend got a car and then when he got a
car he was became really cool and then I
went thought about a radio alone he was
lovely guy Daniel so you traveled up
from Burton to Sheffield on a daily
basis your wayfarer a Yorkshire Wayfarer
and it was like eight quid and you could
just go
there and back everyday was lovely so
then you went from there to where London
and that was a big dream was always to
go to London yes I think I think it's
got a Manchester and what did you think
of London when he got there oh is the
best place in the world isn't it
yeah well yeah he was paid with gold but
you know see you know do you really do
you really like you really love London
when I first came to London I wake up
every day oh I cannot believe I'm in
London did you know how about feeling
when you first when did you first come
down you must have come down quite young
as well I came down and I was well we
were always down I auditioned for take
that when I was 15 yeah got him when I
was 16 travelled the country trying to
apply our wares and sell ourselves to
you know gay clubs this dog racing video
it's okay I'm watching on the on the
train on the way down in the first music
video you made you were like covered in
jelly on your bones and that yeah so
like I've seen it yes there's five guys
on the screen here covered in jelly or
on their asses and they first an extras
like and I'm like just just do it I've
got an interview with probably well yeah
well actually I have got to join them
I've got a copy of my book for you both
and but I also I bought a couple of
copies of loaded magazines which you can
hide the book in for the train but
that's purely a castle or wherever yeah
this book here what reasonably priced it
didn't say the ROP but it's very
reasonably priced and it's a hard copy
it's a hard cover do you get asked what
you think it should be charged up no but
I think the the gay clubs and the video
for do what you like I would ask you all
to what was the pause latex and all of
that and look wasn't it well but why why
we we dressed like that was the reason I
don't know if you can guess the sexual
preference of our manager
well that's the thing when I watched him
it's sort of really all made sense I was
like he's had a big influence on this on
this group of lads yeah you will dress
up and put jelly on your arses that
doesn't sound like a
public I believe me will love it yeah
okay can we talk pause the podcast yeah
we can he's a very litigious man
what does liturgist mean he's going to
come after us and in the interview you
probably come after us
listen there's a your words not a
mustard Lister so also isn't no you come
across as a [__]
so yeah anyway so he put up five grand
to record that video do what you like go
and watch the go watch the version
that's the unedited version see our
arses right now is the most improbably
the most embarrassing video it's oh
that's way worse than anything take that
oh like Backstreet Boys none of them
went that far yeah have you ever seen
Jason Statham dancing in a shame and
video I've ever seen that no on a level
well I think take that blows the door
off that but Jason Statham's dancing in
the video for the shame and I think it
was is is in a similar book anyway so we
did this video we're in latex and I'm 16
whoa I've actually just at that time
know in the gay community no but I'm
completely legal so there's nothing
wrong with that oh and we're in latex
and there's jelly and a girl touches me
which I was very excited about because
she was a model and she was gorgeous it
was like your first model it was the
first model that touches hutch to me yes
it was the first model of many as well
well you know I did alright but so the
video is probably the most embarrassing
video the every street music in the gear
clubs as well no you're in the clubs and
you're sort of doing all of this sort of
gyrate and then that and there's a lot
of leather flying around do you know
like being surrounded by men sort of a
bated breath okay well first of all
after we recorded that video Nigel
martin-smith charged as ten pounds
to receive a copy of that video of
course of course yeah nothing wrong with
that now was that your manager yeah
absolutely nothing wrong why was he
charging we you know you just wanted to
choke if T quit to be made one those
same packaging isn't yes you mustn't
miss a Hokie of course it clear he did
so he charges ten quid each for a copy
of that video of course it was a video
that I couldn't take back to
stoke-on-trent and play to anybody
yeah which you will understand if you've
now seen the videos I'm not was I'm not
going against who you were a little bit
because I know you wanted to succeed but
you come across as like a bit of a
normal lad in terms of like your like
football no no no it was Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory well he because when I
went in your bathroom that's what I sort
of thought right well Nigel had the
golden ticket and right you know it was
like first off the question was what was
it like being in gay clubs and what was
absolutely incredible
right because you're from Newcastle
Burton by Liverpool and I always used to
think that I had a built-in detector for
danger because I always used to manage
to get myself out of scrapes until I
didn't when I got it when I was 17 I got
some notoriety then the scrapes became
impossible to get out of but I always
used to think that oh this is like
something protecting me but the fact is
you know when you grow up where we grow
up there's lots of lovely people but
also there's lots of people whose
special talent is being psychos that is
and you know it's not that you've got an
inbuilt ability to detect danger it's
that you're always looking for it yeah
which is what happened to me when I was
you know cuz I was a latchkey kid you
sort of go out and you miles away from
your house and you nine years old and
you're ten years old you kind of have to
adapt really quickly and learn how to
protect yourself by making yourself
invisible and small because there's a
lot of psychos lot of lovely people too
anyway welcome sister so I was drinking
from an early age and I'd be going to
and pubs and I had these Mel toca boots
and I used to grade where I was going to
that evening with which boots or
trainers are put on and it was like if
it's a dodgy place I'm going to I'm
gonna put on these metal toe cap boots
because it might kick off but if I felt
safe there up on you ever had a metal
frame what do you think probably not you
know there's like an Australian workmen
boots no no I've lived in them pretty
okay for YouTube I tell you what if you
got a kick off one of them yeah [__]
will there you go so I was you sort of
in you you learn the language of the
streets I don't want to put it in that
way you you learn to adapt make yourself
that's all gonna call the problems the
Robbie Williams store and then and the
Rockets grime artist anyway I find
myself in gay clubs and you didn't have
to worry about steel toe cap boots
anymore you know you were just it was an
all fighter than that in good no no I'm
sure that'd be like [__] fights or
whatever but it was just a different
kind of danger now well well not not
really you know it's okay nothing ever
happened to me you know it was just like
heading nesting and you were safe and
there was you know the music was
glorious the energy was incredible and I
loved being there you know so that I'm
I've just left take that we're doing
gigs in gay clubs and you know you have
the preconceptions about going at well
everybody focuses or felis up or
anything there's nothing like that
happened but the first night I was in
one of the gay clubs placed chordal
Akash I was in a dressing room 16 fresh
out of Stoke and there's a guy in the
corner having a wank and like this is
well than this is before Donnie this is
really uncomfortable I've heard about
these places and look it's happening in
front of me and got his back turned talk
to me and then I find out he's the
stripper and he was just pumping his
penis up right but that was the that was
my
introduction so as dangerous as it ever
got towards yeah yeah pleased to meet
you with as dangerous as it ever got
that was it people do think of gay clubs
as quite predatory though don't know
which to the ha Donna I know a lot of
people who think I know it's a good
night refill I think it's changed maybe
the perception down he is but especially
back then not that long ago but back
then it was like gay clubs you know that
was on the site it was like a there was
like queer as folk was around at that
time that sort of thing that queer is
really his folk but similar to that
scene I don't know I didn't watch
queries loaded I but what I got from it
was like it amazing night out if I was
going to go to any club right now I'd go
to a gay night in an instance because
you know when did so all this sort of
kicked off really quickly when you were
very young you've joined take that this
is the spine you don't know if it's
gonna work it might work or may not and
you got this manager there who seemed he
reminded me like a lot of these managers
who have these young boy buns he
reminded me a little bit of the guy who
had NSYNC and the Backstreet Boys in a
sort of a mean you say he's the take to
come after you but he just seemed a bit
wrong I think there's something I didn't
trust you didn't seem like a honest
person in his interviews he'd he didn't
seem like he loved and cared about you
guys he was like well you should be
[__] grateful that was the idea from a
lot of what he said because you said you
know I wanted you in lovers I wanted you
valia was a you're like a member of a
team you want the manager of the
football team to really believe in you
and care about you and if it was just
you were lad who was given a job to do
yeah which instantly you sort of that
was the thing that I was instantly
thrown into my first experience of the
adult world cuz I thought we were going
to join a gang and you know so we're
gonna be in this gang together we're
gonna conquer the world there's gonna be
loads of fun take that yeah and that's
not how it was because you know sort of
join a band and I think that Nigel it's
had heard Gary Barlow's demo tape you
really like them they make
I decided to put a band around him I
didn't know all of this at the time but
I subsequently do now so gas in his own
right is he was sort of like making more
money than his teachers were when he was
13 yeah you know he had a big talent for
the piano keyboard and was going out
into the clubs and making his own money
so he you know he he was confident in
his own ability and then all of a sudden
here is a manager saying we're going to
put these four boys behind you and I
don't think he really wanted four boys
behind it so and then you throw Nigel
into the mix where I think he just saw
me as a problem from day one and he
wanted to kind of control everything and
even down to the coriander in curries
maybe like five chicken tikka masala ZnO
coriander for the boys so it'd be even
down to the insta greed with the Curry's
why I mean like coriander just to be
clear I don't know but I never got to
taste coriander and take that brand is
great are you for that Nigel because I
like coriander anyway I don't know what
the man's like now I don't know who he
is now but at the time it was a very
difficult for me to enjoy myself because
I just felt as though he's very
litigious I've got to pick my words very
carefully you know I just
he wasn't pleasant towards me can I get
sued for that no being pleasant you
didn't feel like he was pleasant to it
you don't know there was a pleasant
relationship there just to saw in the
saunders a bit but and also Gary's
written about this in his book right but
him and Nigel went to Disneyland right
together alone alone right do you feel a
bit left out really did cuz I really
wanted to go over than yeah Gary was
Gary was the favorite and hence was the
start of the problem that I had with gas
you know it was sort of but we'll get
into that LA
we could just do whatever you know it
feels a little bit like this so but you
are quite a dis people always paint you
as a quite a disruptive character do you
know I mean that's what they paint you
as do you think you are we're actually
that is a figure I think that if people
tell you something enough time he and
you become that at that point in time
the rave scene was happening which a lot
of your guests about and also you know
it's like I was in a lily-white pop
group yeah but doesn't mean that I was
going home listening to the Osmonds you
know that's not who I was she knows what
were you listening to I NWA Public Enemy
house music acid house and you know I'd
sort of some a done acid and speed and
ecstasy or by the time that I was 16 so
yes is a public figure I was singing up
you know could it be magic no but I was
so good yeah I wasn't better live in
classes you know this and there was no
social media either so I was getting
away with an awful lot of stuff that you
simply couldn't get away with from for
people that are in the same position
that I was back in the day so I was in
this little white band but also I was a
bit of a nutter you know I had
remaindered me when I'm watching this
there's but behind the scenes videos of
you but the behind the scenes videos of
Gaza
you know what the England team everyone
sort of trying to be you know heads down
south as I was that no the door was
wrong to take that that boys were a
little bit wild but you were just a
little bit more than them I think you
you were a bit more of a wild lad than
what they were
yeah but was like they were innocent but
it just felt like you didn't belong
there
like even when I look back on it that
they all sort of looked like a boy but
and then there's you on the end skinhead
for in just screaming [__] him yeah yeah
there was it wasn't we've the black
sheep I was the black sheep and it
wasn't sort of set up it was sort of
divide and conquer mentality so you know
so god I wanted out like I said before I
wanted us all to be in a gang and I
always wanted also to love each other
and you know common purpose and going
forward together but there was divisions
and you know back home weird stuff was
happening to when you become famous well
you know I was telling a story to help
earlier young galius or residents talk
like yeah residents don't let big up the
long-term massive you know so you become
famous you get a bit of notoriety and
you think it's going to be everything
and you kind of psychologically think
although you I wouldn't have been able
to tell you as a 16 year old this is
gonna fill in all the blanks everything
that I'm missing as a person everything
that isn't in my personality everything
that I'm uncomfortable about is going to
be all sorted out when I become famous
and I saw records or I become an actor
because I wanted to become you get money
and you get money as why don't you get
money to which I didn't think about
really very much was it no for the first
18 months I think we made about hundred
ninety pounds right for the first 18
months how is that the case because they
will have not been making 190 pounds off
you well you kind of nobody's so you
kind of do in you know like you have to
do when you're starting out in any
business you're doing favors for people
you turning up and you're you it wasn't
like X [__] no where people win a
competition and they're superstars you
had to like grind to get off the charts
the old farm its first weddings yeah
yeah exactly and you sort of paid for
your petrol etc etc etc so yeah so for
the I was living off the bank of mom
nobody who's ripping us off I don't want
to suggest that it's just that there
wasn't any money being made because
there wasn't any money to be made and
what happened with us we'd sort of like
we get up in the morning and do a school
assembly and then we do another school
in the afternoon and
then we'd go to a under-18s nightclub a
youth club an over 18s nightclub at
three gay clubs and you'd be all in one
day that might be doing this and we'd be
in our yellow self exhaustedly
well we were young enough to do it
though you know we were full of energy
full of beans this was the golden ticket
this is the way out and yeah it was it
was knackering but and that was not the
thing that I had a problem with at the
time and we used to have these cards and
these cards had a picture of us for like
a promo cover of do what you like the
legendary video that's online and on the
back it would be our fan club address
and these girls would write into us and
we went the length of breaths to the
country and handed out these cards and
we managed to amass 75,000 addresses
which is what I think I mean the power
of a million love songs when a Gary's
songs was a big June but I think the big
thing that got assigned was that we had
75,000 it was data yeah you know it was
data so there was actually a concrete
thing and nobody wanted to sign us at
the time because boy bands weren't
they're eager anymore they've gone out
of fashion and I think it was BMG
decided to take a gamble on us and they
signed us but it was through graft
determination hard work and nothing else
existing back at home because I just
left school and I'm Dyslexic
I can't retain information I spent five
years at my high school sort of acting
the part of somebody that's listening
and taking information in but I I don't
know if it's the same when you were at
school was a lots of coursework it was
at the Arabic yeah did you do it I did
the course work I've onions subjects
that I thought I mean like stuff that
I'm interested in a bit like English and
so I was quite like reading stories and
stuff but other than that so you pitched
that you were good at that I was good at
English that was the one thing I was
good at did you get an A did I well I
got nothing higher than a D
at all after all in any subject yeah
academia just wasn't and isn't for me
and also at the same time you didn't
have dyslexia that wasn't my doing why
do you think it is that so many really
successful people come from no exam
results and stuff like that because a
lot of people I told you are like
ultimate success stories and yet they've
done terrible at school well I think you
know they say that if you're I'm not
gonna liken it to this but if you're
blind you your other senses pop up
maybe I mean I don't know if that's been
proven true so I'm sure the internet
will shout at me and tell me whether
that's right or not but I think it might
be like that it's like okay I'm
ridiculously bad at all of these things
that I'm supposed to be good at there's
actually forming my life and that's
terrifying if what if I can't do this
then I'm going to go nowhere because
that's the information that you're given
when I we did a careers meeting at
school we went around the class asking
people what they wanted to be when they
grow up and he got to me and I said I
wanted to be an actor and he said yeah
that's not gonna happen for you you
should join the army settle down join
the army and that was the sort of you
know it's like a copper resentment quite
easy I'm you know I suck I hold on to a
resentment and they can be yeah but I
they can be really powerful and they can
drive you but also I was going to ask
you about this later on actually can
grind you down cuz I was a butcher few
things and I've picked up on a few
things about you and I thought that
emotion that you have in you is you can
tell it drives you a lot went like what
do you you accepted an award after take
that split and everyone had wrote you
off and he was like that's for you [__]
off and like I thought myself I love
that the speech was epic but also I
thought for you to even give those
people the time of day and your happiest
moment shows how much you've been burned
by how people who wrote you off a lot so
was that in knew from day one would you
say this this emotion that drives you on
did you feel like you had to put all the
eggs in one basket just because people
said you're never going to [__]
nothing the dream wasn't for us the
dream wasn't for me you kind of in
stoke-on-trent you we don't exist
because we're in between two TV channels
we were between Granada in the north and
central in the south so we didn't exist
at all you know the football results
were barely you know the highlights were
barely on the TV in fact the only time
stoke-on-trent was on the TV was for an
advert for carpet world Drayton Manor
Park stoke-on-trent it'll be like we're
there mom
we're there we exist so to answer your
question which I think I am you know
there was the the dream wasn't there for
us you didn't dare think that big
there's a mentality of that happens on
the TV to somebody else that happens on
film to somebody else and then you know
nothing happens at school this is what
happened I get my exam results and I've
got 1d and I can't remember that was in
and miR me mate eight had five or
between us that we'd probably got from
each of those Nan's
and we went and got five cans of bitter
and sat on the bowling-green because he
hadn't done very well either and I was
you know plugging up the courage to go
and tell my mum and my mom is fierce
she's in Christ she's incredibly fierce
and I just needed to numb this impending
information that I'd got to give to her
out of my system so I had these two and
a half cans of bitter ten Benson &
Hedges
and went home and knocked on the door
and he won't came to the door and I said
I've got something to tell ya and she
said I've got something to tell you and
I'm like well you first she said you're
in that band so thank you and thank [__]
for that so the never mind the original
Drive yes
you know the resentment
can be a huge driving factor which has
also gone into the pie chart of my
success but it was I've got a chance at
a dream you know and this was my only
way in and my only way out so that was
the main driving force but what I'm
thinking about resentments a lot now I'm
43 you're 30 right so does that drive
you a lot yeah I was kind of saying on
that last podcast so we heard the yoga
instructor and like my Igor isn't
completely in control of me but I am
aware that I do operate better when I
feel like I've got a point to prove in
an enemy and someone to fight against in
I'm not only gonna beat you I'm going to
annihilate you yeah when the media seem
to put you and Gary head-to-head I had a
thing I was watching thinking if I'm
Robbie in that point in time in my head
I'm like I'm the underdog and not so
yeah when you do I need to try harder
because everyone's like Gary's the
talented one and this that and the other
I'm not just gonna beat young gonna
absolutely smash it
yeah the results sure that you obviously
heard of so that must have been in your
made it well I'm kind of like if you
punch me I glass you hmm and to varying
degrees of success that's work for me in
my life
that particular bit with gas yeah you're
right it's like I'm not just gonna beat
you I'm gonna absolutely annihilate you
and that's going to be my power and my
strength but at some point in your life
because I have countless resentments
that I where do you go to when you're
idling where does Brian I clap you know
your brains in neutral it goes to Joe
Rogan I'd say I think I think now I'm
getting to a point where I feel like I'm
proving my point now yeah you have a
love to yourself about how things are
going on whatever but I don't you you're
scared I mean at my point I'm scared
congratulate yourself too much because
it's like I don't want to get
overconfident they become lazy and then
just rest on my laurels yeah I hate if
you did that yeah so I kind of always
feel like I've got a point to prove a
little bit and only when I I'm really
unquestionably where I think I'm but
long they
well I here's what I think well happy
for you though I think you've got an
unquenchable thirst and I don't think
you will ever realize when you're there
what's annoying is I know a lot of
people are gonna watch this interview
who actually say what you enjoy it they
may say even Robbie said it yeah Robbie
seen it in your suit yeah but I brought
it up and I'm the same you know it's a
car I'm the same but surely it's better
to be a unquestioned unquenchable in
your thirst of success then it just be a
lazy [__] who sits on the code because
I'm all or nothing me like sort of
before oh well that's them and this is
all CEO that's them they get on with
that and if they ever got it they
haven't got it but you know it's like
I've been I'm trying to sort out as a 43
year-old where I put all of that tube
because you know it's like they say that
you'll know if you have a resentment or
you want revenge then then dig two
graves because you're doing your own as
well you're digging your own too so and
but how can you feel like no because at
the way I feel is the reason my own
favors I've got a point to prove
you [__] proved every point you
you're the biggest sullen British meal
artist ever yes I think it's not enough
what would be enough well nothing well
that's the thing it's something that
I've come into realizes and my
three-year-old is it's kind of like my
ISM whatever I've got that drove me to
be the person I am is an unrelenting
monster that doesn't know when enough is
enough there's that way that when you
took drugs and alcohol you were alike
that with that as well yeah I'm really
bad at that but I was incredibly good at
into I was a sort of an Olympian I would
always be the last person awake he knows
like one time I I mean look I've since
ended up in rehab quite a few times so
it's like it's not something that I'm
proud of but like I went to the lengths
of you know I be awake for four days in
a row and I'd be kind of like the last
person at the last party as the dregs
you know so I was how does that feel
though because actually it's obviously
it sounds like somewhat of an
achievement it can actually be a little
bit of a lonely scenario to be
when you're the last person awake and
everyone else has gone home with their
partner or whatever and you're just sort
of left alone a party it feels dreadful
and then you know your body is dependent
on these chemicals that you've been
putting inside and then you have to
withdraw from that and then it's hellish
and when I was not so much now but when
I first got sober I used to watch films
and if there was a party scene I
couldn't carry on watching the film
unless there was the morning after or
the day after be in it was that okay I
come way up that bit because there's the
hangovers like I understand that yeah it
was lonely it was desolate it felt
hellish it's caused ongoing problems
probably for the rest of my life yeah
one thing you said when I was talking
Leon the emails and that because we're
being chatting for quite a while now it
would be fair you said you have what's
called a graph obeah yeah and you said
you don't really like going out in
public a lot and you like meeting new
people is a bit of a funny thing for you
what's that coming from
so now I'm trying to work it out but
because people would be watching you now
and be like Robbie wasn't that the
showman the Mario's on stage belt no
tubes he's the one who's yeah very
confident yeah no that's it's it's all
an act
hmm I'm not that guy I'm not that
confident but that's part of the the
power thing the part of the Argo and
show you I can I can do an impression of
an alpha male or somebody that's really
good garius or somebody that's super
competent but that's not how I live my
life offstage but if anyone about really
as confident as they make Oh surely even
mccracken no but even see even call him
a gross gonna be kinda won't be but the
point you know it's like he might be
near it but I I'm completely in love
with his impression of somebody that's
incredibly confident but I don't believe
that he he totally is but so isn't that
there's something quite interesting
about that though because so if you
can't be that but you can be the guy who
plays that role why
in that person then is it just you it
seems like it's only you really it
doesn't believe that you have maybe
people close to you as well who says
well I think once again I go back to pie
charts I think there's a lot of things
that go into the pie chart of what maybe
become the way I am as regards to public
stuff and meeting new people and getting
along with them but I when I got sober
it was kind of when I was talking about
filling in the blanks for my what I was
hoping that my career would bring me
it's like Coke and lager and ecstasy
filled in all of those blanks and then
it took away the medication that I was
medicating myself with and I was left
with all the blanks and I'm still I
haven't had a drink for 18 years I'm
still sort of filling in the blanks I
have an ism and alcoholism and addiction
but also my own special ISM that makes
me want to isolate that makes me want to
keep away from people that doesn't make
me feel safe when I'm there and I don't
want to be that guy you know it's like I
don't want to be him why not what I
don't want to I don't want to be the
Hermetic isolator yeah because I like
people I like finding out about people
and I like people's company and I also
like to laugh and I want to laugh more
and yeah it's just I'm in my head a lot
and I you know the ISM that I've got
takes me away and I'm very anxious and
scared fearful yeah I've seen that in
one of your interviews backstage where
you've been you've been pushed off stage
by someone or something like that and I
could say it was like it upset you
and I thought [__] hell he's quite a
vulnerable person but then I watched a
race or I seen this was toured to start
your career you seemed very vulnerable
and then I watched another interview
with you about 15 years later like right
afterwards and I thought [__] hell I
can say you've had to hone that active
and harden up a bit as well well the
thing that you saw was a document
called nobody Sunday and they were
coming to document me being on tour and
as it happens I just got sober so I'm
I'm literally that that bit of footage
where I'm pushed off the the stage by
this guy in Germany I'm doing a gig in
Stuttgart and I'm just singing supreme
or whatever one of my songs and then all
of a sudden I found myself being pushed
up in the air and then I land on the
audience and then I land on my back and
I look up to the stage and this guy's
looking down at me and this guy wants to
kill me and he looks like Mickey winder
the guy that's looking after me
backstage and I'm thinking why does it
make you because it went so quick but in
those moments you it feels as though you
know sometimes so you're sore but I've
said yeah so so also I was dealing with
mental illness I was dealing with
depression I was dealing with whatever I
was covering up by how much you were
very emotional yeah
and in in those moments when people get
sober for the first time and they put an
amount of time together they're the most
damaged the most vulnerable the most
sensitive so that that film
nobody someday go watch the the bit
where he pushes me off stage the guy
thought he was blessing me wasn't very
well and he thought that I wasn't the
real Robbie Williams and you know yeah
how'd she do that guy looks too sober to
be Robbie was like yeah yeah like the
exactly like the the Paul conspiracy
from the Beatles yeah you know four or
five relevant died and then someone else
no playing good do you believe that or
because you've been around everyone
she's not the same person yeah she used
to be the mistletoe be clipped up add
added added to a conspiracy correlate
with the with the dramatic music playing
underneath where YouTube we don't need
the dramatic music on conspiracy videos
we don't need you [__] love castles
you do take a lot of Titus Lee you take
a lot of time on tour that's how you
found us you find weird kooky people to
watch who don't really have a real
message but just latch on to other
people's messages and then pretend and
user what and then so do you watch a lot
of conspiracy theory and that must feed
a little into the world the mental
illness mental illness wanting to but
Begay vania groups beginners [__] so I'm
yeah I kind of with the invention of the
internet and all the information being
gathered at the same time it's very very
easy and entertaining and enjoyable and
not I would suggest best for your mental
health you can find yourself going down
and rub it off completely and it's a lot
of fun but if you mix that with
marijuana you can find yourself in a
house in Beverly Hills going to your
wife move to Montana there's a bomb just
about to be dropped it's gonna go off so
you know where's her response there by
the way she would have gone in Montana a
short time she would have just gone okay
baby let's do it go okay let's go you
know you're sort of well-connected now
have you ever been confronted by anyone
who's mentioned Illuminati [__] anything
like that you must have been because
there was a point where it sounds like
you were untouchable there was a point
where I remember then the day that you
got that massive album deal and you were
sort of being shepherded through public
everyone was trying to get your picture
everyone he's the most successful man in
the world it's gonna be bigger than the
Beatles all these guys are you
suggesting the big sense might decline
in my popularity my membership to the
Illuminati has been revoked no but I
think you're paranoid suggesting that so
at that point you'll rise like it almost
seemed a little bit bizarre this is what
you were an amazing artist that I
remember loving you as a kid like being
like God that guy's gonna be into some
extent when you were talking about that
I felt a little bit not resentful
towards you but I'm talking about what
like what a great showman
what a showman you were and you sort of
like I've took that
real instruction as a kid and sort of
like well we you know I had to be a
showman and then you get this mess why
you felt was over yeah maybe I felt a
little bit maybe as a kid you sort of
really latch onto that you feel a little
bit like that's reality you believe it
and you're like I can do that as well
and I think I've not been on a similar
journey to yours and not anything nearly
as intense maybe some side different
conclusions but it is interesting to
hear you talk about that and isn't that
what being a showman is thought surely
you have you're wanting people that
believe are certain we we I didn't smoke
when you were smoke and I said to you I
think nerds like that real artists angst
and quite a few people have been on our
podcast and done that thing where their
identity is completely the pain that
they're in and they don't seem able to
escape that pain or they've now find a
way to monetize that pain so they almost
have to stay there so it's a little bit
I'd like to think that you know where my
pain lightly I'm not I'd like to I'd
like to think now that is my truth you
know so I don't want to be I don't want
to you know
oh woe is me this is ya know it's like
I'm now sort of I was in that and now
I'm outside of that having a look at it
and going okay how do we deal with the
rest of of how do I deal with the rest
of my life knowing that this is this is
the truth about me is that what do we do
with that is it trying about yeah why
why the whole thing bothers a book
called revealed and is 518 pages of why
I it there's a lot you know sick I've
been doing therapy since I was 21 so
we've only we've got what two hours two
and a half hours three hours if I'm
interested in yeah you know I don't
think I can explain it all plus also
it's like I know you know but it gets an
awful lot of people into trouble and I
also you know love a lot of those people
that I'd be saying well this happened
this happened this happened in this
happened it's not awkward when you write
in a book and you sort of really want to
tell your story but you also don't want
to because everyone has shitty things
happen to them by people that they love
and ultimately you forgive them in ten
years or five years maybe for me and you
will be 25 yeah
you kind of want to tell the whole story
accurately but also you don't want to
throw people under the bus that's that's
not what the book is about
right you know it's like this isn't a
book in my voice talking about my life
right that's that's for another time
this is very different my friend Chris
Heath who's over there boy follows has
followed me around he did a book with me
called feel in 2000 and 2004 and it was
well acclaimed critically acclaimed
people loved the book for its honesty
and its brauneis and people coming up to
me and saying I can't believe I want has
she been in that book and it was like
well to be honest with you I've been
ready so I don't know what I said
and I love hanging out with Chris and I
wanted to do a follow up to that book
and the follow up to that book has been
Chris following me around with a with a
notepad and did you know a recording
equipment and following and recording my
every movement so it's not the classical
biography that you would think it is
it's sort of nice like enough
celebrities in parts and in other parts
being gossipy but in all the parts being
thoughtful and hopefully funnier when
when you've said something on an
interview because you do you drop people
in it regularly I've notice that I was
gonna say did it make you assess some of
those situations as well do you ever
think wait I wasn't writing that looking
back you're like [__] actually yeah yeah
many times but I I do want to entertain
and I have limited talents and I see it
like a bit like a bar fight mhm
you know it's like if I'm on the TV I
want to make that moment a gold you know
like like you did when you were growing
up and you'd see people on chat shows or
you'd see people when I was growing up
here it'd be sort of like Freddy star
Muhammad Ali rod hull and EMU and all of
these people that would go on and make
like TV gold and I see it as kind of
like my duty to go on and do TV gold
well you know make up the numbers or you
know it's like I know I want to win I'm
really competitive and I see it a bit
like a bar fight and I will grab the
first thing that comes to my mind and I
will use it's not competitiveness though
going about the tooth but you're
obviously you're you're in a five-month
was there a little bit of you that
thought I don't want to make up the
numbers are what I have to be one of the
main faces if that's what how it's going
to go down
no I thought that there was probably the
mechanics of how people looked after in
the band and I have an ability to be
very resentful and use that as a power
and if I feel as though there's an
injustice did I want to be one of the
main people I didn't even know I was
allowed to or you know it was even I was
more like touching my forelock at the
time thank you sir thank you this is ten
pounds for the video sir thank you very
much sir you know so I didn't even know
that that was a possibility for me
because the dream was so big but then
somebody suggested that I do and then
yeah I've kind of found my feet and
wanted to be more than and thought while
I sang could it be magic and I can do
these people seem to respond they don't
say I'm she stood out straight with so
but whereas one of the other lots not so
much I mean well you know they dear
friends of mine I've been through a lot
with them they're their family members
and family members in every sense of the
word
is that weird no though after you at one
point you had a massive falling-out with
them I mean you said a lot of things
about them and now it's like well
actually I do forgive them I'm not sure
why didn't you come and meet them oh
well I'll tell you about that too but
the thing is it's like I go I go [__]
atomic you know and it's like if you
upset like with the Gallagher's that'll
roll on and on and on and on it's like
if I get miffed or if I go upset or if I
feel as though you put me down I just I
want to kill you and there was there was
a what you've got the same thing yeah we
have talks where I sort of here ends me
in a lot right I thought the setup okay
that was unfair and I thought it was
unjust and that made me rageful and the
stuff that happened when I left hate
that was like I was awful with gas
and I thought as though I had good
reason you know not now not as a 43 year
old with a bit of time under my belt
looking back on it you know he didn't
know that somebody in the band had this
in him that this atomic sort of anger
where I'm going to make sure that you
know not only do I win but I stamp all
over you and I keep stamp in his career
I was pretty [__] but I don't think
that that was all yourfault would be
fair it was he just didn't release the
right records after after he went solo
but there's a lot of problem saying that
yeah I think and that that must say that
in this documentary that I was where
they did the reunion did you say that
yeah you were supposed to come and meet
them afterwards that they all met
together a new sort of video recorded
message where you sort of you said
positive things but you didn't show up
and there was a slight stitch up right
with that documentary i stitched myself
up with my attitude in the documentary
quite a bit but there's a slight stitch
up because the the thing was we were all
gonna leave messages to each other that
was what I was told right so I sort of
like I leave a message to Howard and and
I'm thinking that how it's gonna leave a
message back to me and that's it I
didn't know about the the real the
meetup that was going to made you a bit
of a well you know it's all right I felt
bad for the boys because at the end of
the documentary the premise was the boys
were going to get back together at this
hotel and then maybe Robbie Williams was
gonna turn up I didn't know that was
happening and that was when they played
my messages to all the boys so this was
scripted though by the the people behind
at the whole time yeah yeah so watch her
but there was one of the lads and the
one who's the DJ he was like I wanted it
I wanted it and it if you watch if you
want to end his life did you ever watch
the what was the the documentary when
they'd get he's 17 together and the
remains the reunion that was awkward
though it was nobody was it was very
entertaining he's a great watch but
watch everybody's story about those
times yeah it caused mental illness it
depression it caused you know as much as
there were highs watch everybody's story
and it's always pro generally that
closely and that length of time toward
isn't it loads no it is I also think
it's interesting cuz obviously you you
got into a band but it wasn't like the
way that I sought a that was like it's
like the like as a kid you're like it's
the Beatles so all these guys have come
from the same place you've all got a
common goal and it was very similar to
when you thought it would be but naively
as a kid you're like these guys they all
know they love each other like why would
they argue like why would any of this
happen and I think there's like anxiety
around that kind of dynamics it's not
Travis I say that we didn't love each
other I would have liked was to love
each other in a different kind of way I
don't mean man loaf right
I just mean you know it would have been
there was no chance for us to be a
cohesive unit but also at the same time
how often do you get five guys together
that then go off in Psalm 19 million
albums and they go into the stratosphere
then not many me put people in the
history of the world I've ever been in
so who knows how to deal and managed
Lord's Road and maintained that people
could have done that better from what we
see I mean especially you see the
characters people could have done that
better yeah did you look at other bands
and look at their dynamic cuz obviously
you guys so you guys doing all the
biggest shows at those times were you
looking at other bands and being like
our brother Pete boy zone Oh what do you
know what I mean that sort of thing but
we gotta prefer these 17s records yeah
okay but everybody in the house of loves
are tuned deep I'm going deep babe ed
yeah deep down you look like yes but we
were we were there we were the daddies
you know there was nobody that was that
could match us with sales gigs you know
like when I'm looking at a bunch a lot
there cuz one thing I hit me when I'm
watching this documentary is the
screaming girls and [__] like I'm like
[__] hell I would have been mint like
that that would have been the funnest
thing ever getting mobbed by girls all
the time I mean life's great what
must have been awesome was a fun well
the temperature of what was happening
back home is weird too you know so I had
this ons for me I'm just saying this is
my experiences not anybody else's
experience what was happening was we had
this unsafe work environment where I
didn't feel appreciated and you know the
the opposite of that was happening so I
didn't feel safe there
I came home and I became famous and you
think that that's gonna be absolutely
amazing and instantly I found out that
it wasn't because where you used to be
able to go to with anonymity you now
come and now not only can't you can't go
there are you going to get your head
kicked in because being famous and stalk
is different to being famous in London
yes yeah under let me qualify that with
my the place that I'm from I love it to
bits and I love the people but also we
do breed a lot of psychos and you you
can't be invisible anymore you can't
make yourself small you can't disappear
the built-in radar for danger doesn't
work the way it used to because you
haven't got any of your tricks because
you're too too visible and and I like
going out yeah so this was a problem not
only that we sort of had outside the
house at any given time that could be
like 10 girls to 150 girls just wait you
know a problem that's Robbie I thought
however the girls well they were you
know they were all under 16 right you
know some problems annoying yeah right
shrill could you know if just something
I've got as any of you over the age
that's at least one years old it's funny
that that's your first thought is well
that's exactly what I would
go and pick the legal ones out as for
right the the that be that many people
outside the house that the police used
rafter cordon off the road because it
wasn't safe for god yeah in Stoke and
I'd sort of and my mom was beside
herself because now you know you sort of
make yourself vulnerable yeah I'm the
man of the house it's just my mom and my
sister and I know that people are gonna
burglars I know because I've been told
yeah people have come into the house
there's other stuff that went on where I
was not very safe to say the least that
what you were referring there were you
go in the email so I come here come here
so I'll give people a hint that sort of
story because to repackage it yeah you
got involved with girls and that it may
be one of them it wasn't nowhere no it
wasn't the girls so much it was
something else let's just say my life
became in danger right and it wasn't
safe for me to be I mean I'd love to say
I'd love to say no I can't I don't know
I had to know how a month I don't know
what's going to get you yeah trouble you
can get in by saying that you're naming
names yeah but I used to sleep with a
gun let's put it that way right and guns
name it was called desi Eagle Derrick
Derrick Eagles Derrick eagle yeah and
this is like when I was 17 in England
yeah see you carried a gun with you
around well I did at the house because
you'd being told well there was the
stuff that was about to happen to me and
yeah it was it was touch-and-go which
also is sort of caused a problem with
feeling safe probably for the rest of my
life yeah you know you experienced that
kind of this trauma that's about to
happen where you're gonna end your life
and you know you need to protect
yourself but you also need to protect
your mom and your sister too do you ever
feel in danger which would because you
are as recognizable as it gets in
Britain yeah do you ever feel like
anyone at any moment do you have that
when you walk around the streets or
anything
no no not now but there was a period in
my life where people just would either
wanted to kill me or punch my facing and
that was like the was what's the period
when you're sixteen seventeen eighteen
you're informative called formative
years formative years so and I was a bit
of an animal at the same time I wanted
to go out and I didn't want that to stop
me and I shouldn't have and I got into a
few scrapes in a few places that I
shouldn't have been in but yeah I used
to have I used to sleep with an aerosol
can underneath my pillow too with a
slicer brilliant last eleven yes because
I'd seen James Bond yeah and I was going
to use this as a flamethrower all of
these things happen so I wasn't in the
Millennium music but now I saw you you
were up man
so you're asking me you're asking me
what which what was it fun to be honest
with you I think the girls
well the girls yeah look yeah okay that
was that was great that bit of my life
was wonderful that carried on for a
longer time limit until I met Ida in
fact it became that great that I didn't
know how I was going to give up that can
you be a married person yeah so how many
can you name some people I might know
who you sort of slept with yeah camera
but not on camera I get into a lot of
trouble this is a lot of famous women
northern you are quite prolific I was a
prolific swordsman yes I mean it's no no
no Harry Styles but yeah is he doing
bits right now he's doing bits you're
proud of them do you say look at yeah
I'm suing me
yeah I I had the sword on you know so
going back to was it fun yeah of course
there was lots of bits that were fun
because there was just experiences that
were blowing our mind we'd sort of go
from flicks nightclub where there was
one man and a dog watching us to gmx
arena where there's 8,000 people to then
to a stadium where there's 50,000 people
and it's
all mind-blowing life-affirming
incredible stuff just the stuff that was
going on behind the camera was too much
for me to deal with to enjoy it fully
but I think that's everybody's story
watching any you watch any like behind
the music and then it turns sour you
know must have met other guys like
Justin Timberlake seems like quite a
well-adjusted individual or I don't know
I'm sorry pre-programmed or what he was
Disney programmed from day one was new
it's not like you grown up and stock
yeah like you weren't ready for this
like the way yeah I don't know you know
Sakai I know that I there's one person
it's really famous that I mean I won't
mention his name but I'm a massive fan
of him a similar sort of age and he
crushes it and he's incredible and I
remember just having a conversation with
him on the phone and we just went on for
for like 45 minutes going and you feel
that way and you think that way and and
it was it was great to know that I
because you can be quite isolating the
experience that I'm having in this
lifetime can be quite isolating it's
just great to know that somebody else
going that's exactly how I feel - so yes
there are people but like Justin
Timberlake he's incredible - but you
know it's like but the Americans as a
whole are very very good at giving you
their representative I'm not saying that
Justin's representative on stage and in
interviews isn't him yeah because it
might be he's you know he's he's
incredible at what he does but who knows
you know it's like who knows it was an
element that sure I mean you talk about
people that you've met before you said
there's a photograph of you and - Park
what was it like meeting him he's the
first person I've ever spoken to me like
who've met - and took me eye to puck is
like the greatest ever like yeah he was
we were at a Versace party I've been
invited over there by Donatella I think
I was singing I can't remember either
which way I was with two pack and he was
wonderful and I'm big hip-hop head have
been for since I can remember and here I
was with a hero of my
and look you know he is incredibly
charismatic looked amazing in clothes
proper man-crush wanted to tell him that
no his lyrics didn't do it just drop one
and he didn't hear it and then I thought
I back away but he was really affable
and you know he was inclusive and he it
was it was weird you know it was weird
what was weird not the meeting of the
two pack was him working with the LAPD
was his security right and what we were
getting up to at the time that was
nefarious that was weird was kind of
like it's weird because you okay yeah am
I gonna get sure what if I come to
America yeah you're wide range you say
LAPD there's a lot of rumors that the
LAPD were involved in the his murder as
well because they were employed by Suge
Knight who some people think was
involved in the killing I can neither
confirm or deny that I'll bet you that I
know oh yeah top conspiracy it's one of
them yeah I've got my I've got my own
thoughts Shooks a nice guy I met him he
was a lovely guy lovely guy
actually my always present stone school
well my mom came mom came to Los Angeles
and she said I've just been outside and
this chap came over to me in this big
car and he came out and he was like
[__] this and you [__]
that cuz I parked in front of the master
- how dare you talk to me like that I'll
have you know that my son lives in this
house and he will come and get you and I
said to this man what was his name and
he said Sharky night-night and no he/she
was widely milk but she completely got
me I was like you've told Suge Knight
that Robbie Williams will get him it was
a good stitch Obama mother so it was
with to park at the beasts musashi show
and he was a charming man
it's precious that novel isn't it when
you and people who were the greatest at
what they did you had that time with
them that no one will ever get that yeah
I never met I've met and been around a
lot of them to stage we you a TV or
career by their what stage will you I
probably met him no no wasn't all this I
just left take that and I was searching
for a direction what do you consider
your prime net worth net worth is that
which I knew going into that weekend
that it was all downhill from there
really really is like this was it can't
get any bigger where you come out upside
though yeah that's us a fun I'll be
watching so far nothing Jesus Jesus
Christ yeah I mean how many people was
that 135 thousand each night and was
that more than the other people who done
that worth Oasis yes okay just check one
extra extra night longer than there was
a lot of I could have done more night
yeah I did I just kept it what you had
cuz I can get any tickets I think we
could explain yeah yeah sure okay the
next step the next never yeah I could
still do it I could do one night at
Knebworth yeah thanks with a lot of
thanks for the belief with a lot of
support a lot of singing a lot yeah yeah
no no listen what's the sound alright
would take those videos I feel good no
you just perform to one point too many
people this year so stuffs still good on
the live front I mean I could see some
60 70 thousand people like constantly in
these big stage yeah not you doing all
over Europe what's it like the sing in
front of like that many people I feel
well there's many times that you feel as
though it's that euphoric and that
amazing that you wish to die in that you
just think that actually can't get any
better than this right now the feeling
that I'm feeling it you should just end
it now and I'd be happy and that'd be it
obviously I'm not going to do that I've
got wonderful life and I've got charming
children and a wonderful wife that would
miss me very much so I'm not going
anywhere but
as good as it gets because on the other
hand yeah is the ISM that works and this
you know the shy unsure scared some
nights it's seventy thousand people
looking at you and I'm terrified because
it's really odd it's really weird to be
that person that all of those eyeballs
that are centered on and I don't know
who I'm gonna get each night whether I
turn up Rob Robert Williams or whether
Rob Robbie Williams turns up and
sometimes Robbie Williams doesn't turn
up and I have to do it by myself and
when he doesn't turn up I'm just jelly
legs and petrified though nobody can
tell I nobody can tell which is kind of
some amazing trick that I've got not
even my wife you know I'll come off and
shook up I had an absolute nightmare
tonight you know it can be okay yeah I
was I've had podcasts before and then
others nowhere near the same thing but
like where people have thought all that
was good normally that was a [__]
shovel yeah
yeah yeah exactly the same I've seen you
did a review of so many people say so
when people say that was good
do you actually then give them a
detailed explanation of why like the
Eddie Hall podcast for example smashed
it I was like well yeah because Eddie
was great Eddie was the perfect guest I
was actually a mess because I was like
in or of this guy who I've looked up
there for five years and then I realized
that I was stumbling over me words all
the time things but that was covered up
because Eddie was so good I mean mister
mr. Hall and one more question
what an inspiration he is yeah yeah
we've cuz I Kings of stop yeah I I
watched that at a time that wasn't very
well and this year I had a problem with
my back goth right it's in the bottom of
my back and I had a slipped disc in the
middle of it and then I went on tour and
there was a lot of stress revolving
around it because there was some fine
the issues where if I didn't complete
why I had to complete then we were going
to be poor and I couldn't walk and I
couldn't lie down so I was been in a bad
way this year that's weird though
because I'm now looking at you like a
man who's going to work to make sure you
could provide for his family yeah yeah
but nobody would look at you in that way
because it's Robbie just rocking the
millions up and that's what people would
think oh yeah but there was going to be
something bad happened if I didn't if I
didn't follow through with the
commitments that I've got it was gonna
be - stuff it wasn't me going out to you
know make money it was me actually now
I've got to go and do this so we don't
get minus this amount of money yeah I
couldn't and you know it's like I love
my kids love my wife and I'm very proud
that I get to furnish their life in an
amazing fashion and here was something
that was going to happen where I may not
be able to do that and it was incredibly
stressful and I was having injections
like 15 or 20 injections each night to
get me to get on stage and then in
between those gigs I'd sort of be rocked
in pain so I spent months in abject pain
and it had an effect on me and I ended
up in ICU something went on in my brain
and they found something up there and it
was scary anyway so I come out of ICU
and a go home and I'm watching the
aerial podcast and I just need it was
the right time right place I'm very
grateful for that podcast because you
know it's sort of the strength that's
needed for him to be him you know his
[__] inspirational yeah at that
moment in my life I really needed to
hear that message because you know there
was a stoicism that the he has that's
yeah inspirational go back to your live
shows you on one of the documentary so
watch us or pollen apart your own songs
your like on this choruses [__] and
that's [__] and and I just go through
the motions some things that like you
seem that it pissed off in this at this
point and via interview do you still
feel that way because that was a bit
quite a while ago
yeah songs we like now so plagued by
self-hatred and plagued by self-doubt
still trying to figure out why that is
but I'm sure it's in the book somewhere
throwing back to the book Oh Andy it's
incredibly uncomfortable it's incredibly
uncomfortable to deal with because I
found as though it's a place that I'm
used to and it's a place that I find
comfort in and I don't know how to get
out of it I don't know how to reprogram
the brain to one would be nice to be
calm and serene that would be great but
just to reprogram the brain to think
positively about anything including
myself I better than I was in my
twenties but I'm still not great but I'm
much better than I was in my twenties
yeah when people used to write bad
things about me I'd be like that's good
but I can go ten deeper than that so I
used to want to put at least wait a call
once just I've just got a flashback Y
this is when M&M came out and he said
you made a lion about how are you gonna
how are you gonna hurt someone who
struggles themselves yes and you quoted
that in an interview around that Turner
thought but I'd want to be competitive
about people saying bad things about me
so I'll butter you with that well about
this what about that was the strength
come from then when everyone had [__]
written you off and said he's nothing
without take that if you're such a
negative person you had to believe in
yourself in order to pick yourself up
place somebody else in
- you know there's I don't know is that
Robert or Robbie but I don't know but
there's a giant in there - you know
there is there is this whole hodgepodge
of this self-hatred and self-doubt
but somewhere somewhere you know there
what the I think it's ego both ways
maybe the self agent now and the self
doubt is ego as well as the ego being
the upgrade but somewhere in there is
somebody that can channel strength and
and it may not be real but I convinced a
lot of people that it was so was it real
or is it real yeah you know but I do
believe there's somebody in there -
that's you know that's Channel Zeus at
what point did you realize after he's
been written off that I made it back and
now I'm actually gonna be stronger on my
own than I ever was in the band
I was buoyed by cocaine ecstasy and
Drambuie at the time so I was sort of
self-medicating in so I don't know if
there was any thoughts about what was
happening next I was gonna happen but
you know when people just I was I was
actually as long as there was the
self-doubt self-hatred but it was also
this blinkered view that I'm just going
to get this that's what's going to
happen weirdly is that that positive
visualization that kind of yeah but I
didn't know that I was doing that and I
wasn't employing that as a tactic to
overcome this other stuff it's like no
I'm gonna go here I'm gonna take on the
world and I'm gonna win you seem a lot
less calculated in that sense than some
other people who seem to map out things
and then just go down that I think they
know more about it now right back in 95
96 the the secret the documentary hadn't
come out there wasn't books about it
there was no talk about positive mental
visualization but when I read about it
and heard about it watch these
documentaries then I thought to myself
oh well that's what I did was like Idol
vision ah yeah it's like you must have
it I don't have it why not
it's you do have it because you're going
to go to wherever you want to go to and
you will have it but I can just see it
and feel it and it is palpable that the
power and the intensity I suppose your
is more of a gentle positive mental
visualization do you do that or not no
it's really interesting you say that
because actually I just don't think I'm
the same character in public as I would
be privately sometimes and so I'll tone
it back a little bit maybe because down
the years people have said to me you're
a little bit too intense what in private
in private and in public with your
positive mental visualization I'm not
sure everybody
or maybe just like in general
personality side of things so people
just see it less and that's why I find
it quite interesting when you were
saying you you like being around people
I like being around people but I used to
really love being around people and
maybe love being around people a bit too
much and so in the opposite way so I can
almost appreciate that you want to take
yourself out of that environment a
little bit or want to go back into that
exactly yeah well because because like I
said I like people unlike their company
and you like all people though like gee
do you find you on those people when you
go to those parties you can get on with
absolutely anyone yeah but it takes it
out at me you know it's because I don't
have the the medication do you need to
make those sort of things enjoyable do
you think you were in the room at those
times when you were with those people so
through what you know you say you feel
by trying boolean drugs and do you how
often do you think you were in the room
and sort of present in those situations
in those times when I was having it so I
was present in the fact that I was being
highly you know I was full octane but it
wasn't me because it was an exaggerated
version of myself I had a lot of fun a
lot of fun happened but then there was
the obvious terrible nightmare of the
calm down of whatever was happening so
was I myself in those situation what was
your drug of choice was your favourite
[Music]
cocaine but ecstasy was the one that did
it was the first taking of the tablet
and then the the feeling of the euphoria
and
the thing the feeling of we should
always live like this everyday all day I
know really tried did you have any
experiences I think you mentioned in an
email where you were like where I was on
the stage and I was off meat it's like
have you ever had any things where you
were like I can't believe I did that
yeah nothing that I could say that
wouldn't get me in trouble most of the
time most of the time most of the time
for my yeah in take that we danced we
danced so hard we that the show took so
much out of us that you really couldn't
take anything to get you to to enjoy it
so we were good boys we worked really
hard and most of my adult life I've been
sober and I've definitely been mainly so
99% of the time sober whilst I've been
on stage but there have been there have
been blitz let's say but it wasn't it
wasn't fun you know it wasn't a fun
thing that happened there was this time
when I was off my head in front of
80,000 people and that was the life it
wasn't it was it was a nightmare you
know so I intend not to do that again
why did I say something you said that
you were you've had a few experiences
with girls and [__] like that on stage
and we'll do a second podcast can I go
for smoke yeah yeah yeah you're really
good with them are you blessed with the
same ability to have conversations when
you're not doing yeah yeah that's got
the problem nest yeah at all times
pretty much whether you are drunk or not
how it started basically was we were
like having all these chats and you know
we're better stop [__] recording this
at some point because it we he would
have me like cry and laughing and I was
like it's not happening since how did
you meet Scott he worked for a buying
average you to grind together
cut the middleman out let's make all our
money that's what they say about
grounder very often and let me let me
ask you this question to who's like
because I know that you were hampering
for sponsorship yeah and I just wondered
how that was gonna happen however
because you're allowed to say whatever
you want however you want to say it and
an awful lot of this stuff you know you
would never get away with on terrestrial
TV you would never get away with in most
living rooms which is why I find you
entertaining and why I watch you know
every podcast that you do how do you go
from not having what's it got
sponsorship yeah yeah fine this how does
how does somebody from coral go actually
know this is a Goa we're gonna we're
gonna give them some money
corals just to start we've been
approaching major music artists and
trying to get them to fund our projects
I'm one of them yeah Kylie said you'd be
good to chat and so we knew someone at
the top who when it went to tender they
said why don't you pitch for it and we
put in a legit pitch luckily if somebody
at coral was a very smart lad Elliott
Elliott and a lot of other people were
smart and I mean it's if the problem is
it takes a lot of middle-aged white men
to get through who all go oh I couldn't
show this to my kids or whatever yeah I
think after one chat where you say to
someone it's much real demographic in
the 35 mil really but I mean they're big
on by my record it's it's not it's
expanding though it's changer than that
do you know I mean the big other none so
guess what's the I'm sure there's a lot
you can't talk about but is there like
what are the plans for the true Jordy
Channel interesting um we can't tell you
yet we will tell you we can't tell we
can't so Casey yeah we're starting a
business basically we're gonna have the
wrong company and we've got long term
plans where this is always going to
happen the podcasts always gonna happen
Lawrence true Jordie and Robbie winning
we've won a LC always happen this year
we wanna grow it as a front three RB
hell yeah I do
yes
a good one it's not so yeah we want to
make you excited about that bigger
things I want to get big big big [__]
deals I want to make as much money as I
can
you're gonna get it it's gonna happen
you've got that that stealing that
determination I don't know you're only
going for and go get it so right now I
make no boundaries and I'll tell you
what one ask when you split would take
that they described that moment is such
a [__] weird moment it was like you
were in the room and they were like yeah
with being there thinking about doing
the next chair as a fall and you're like
alright then and apparently it didn't
even like I'm doing anything and you're
like and you're like guess I'll be off
then and there was a bit of melon on the
partly this melon on this side at the
room and you went and you were just
about the time you walked off the the
rehearsal rooms to the sound of my own
feet and I was like I'm going through
the door and I'm I'm taking this melon
by then lettuce and that was it no no
you actually stick their head [__]
around
it's definitely gone definitely go just
for comedic effect jump back in event it
was such a panic and then so what was
happening was I was dreadfully unhappy
dreadfully unhappy with how I was being
treated and also I'd saw got a raging
alcohol running along the side of that
it's a heady mix they said that they had
no idea how bad it was like you hid it
from them cuz we would have all assumed
I didn't exactly I did I didn't exactly
hide it but it was it was very it was
very it seemed very normal
you're a young lad you go get drunk they
didn't see what was happening when I go
back to the hotel room he was carrying
on uh-huh yeah they didn't see that so I
wasn't really hiding it from anybody per
se so anyway I said to the lads
after this tour I'm gonna leave the band
but we were rehearsing and as you know
take that at the time did lots of
dancing and
choreography was never my big strong
point and learning routines never been
my big strong point and me being drunk
every night didn't mix with the intense
focus that was needed to put together at
all
so I was letting the side down and the
lads had a meeting without me and could
see that this was a problem and said
look I think he should go now before
that before the tour starts to prove
that we can do this as a four-piece and
I came in and I rehearsed as usual
lackadaisically and that holding that
moment feel though you must have been
pretty upset there it felt felt very
strange it felt like a release like I'd
been relieved at the pressure that I was
feeling but also there was terrified
about what the future would hold in that
moment I got in a car with my Mallon
drove back to stoke-on-trent face on it
you were the face sad face
Wilson yeah my new best friend will form
a group together yeah and so I'm you got
a glass door or something after the van
and I went home and my mom was moving
into this new place and she was shifting
stuff in and I looked up into the loft
and I said you're never gonna believe
this
I've been sacked and she's on you don't
know how much trouble you're in you're
gonna there's so much stuff to do with
lawyers it's gonna be such a hassle
there's gonna be press and did it and I
was like I felt a bit beat up by it
melodrama
yeah brought wild I've got this Malin
with the face on it and you know kind of
wanted a cuddle and I was you know this
hour remember it might have been
different but I was like oh okay so I'm
in trouble there now I'm in trouble here
and then I got a phone call from a
friend of mine it's a record producer
and he was friends with the great and
good and he said we're going to San
Tropez this Friday and I'm like Stoke
San Tropez I'll go to San Tropez so
there I was with Dodi al-fayed
hate moths Alma
and Naomi Campbell Duran Duran as anyone
famous there no there was nobody famous
there which was unfortunate cuz that's
what I was into at the time yeah my
collections was there when all the
Yeates
and I had a wild time none of us could
sleep I don't know what it was but none
of us could get any war anyway so I'd
been there for like a couple of days and
I'm around the swimming pool with
Michael Hutchence and the phone goes by
the pool and I see my coaching's pick it
up and he's like the Michael's goes Rob
EADS it's your mama
so my collections passes me the phone
and my mom so right it's gone to the son
you're in trouble it's gonna be on the
front page you need to come home now and
I'm like okay I'll come home now so I'm
surrounded by the grave good being
berated by my mum sorry guys I've gotta
go home mum says I've got to come in now
so and then I flew back to
stoke-on-trent and the ensuing publicity
surrounding my departure happened and I
hid out in a house in Winslow for about
two months just confined to barracks and
just stayed in this house and hid away
I've seen them you know the girls the
reaction when you left you were in the
streets flailing around and like when
they were in the streets lately with
girls are yeah the girls run crazy like
what I liked it are you sort of looking
at the thing and [__] get up all the
yourself will you taking the worse than
me that was how blinds help you know in
Germany because I think somebody
tragically committed suicide at the time
but I was just so deep into vodka and my
own thoughts that I didn't even consider
what was going on outside okay there's
there's a few questions that arise from
that is one is why what who put that
publicity out like why was it on the
front page of the Sun do you know who
did that yes and you'd slightly resent
the way that it happens and
the manager and no no no it wasn't it
was somebody that I was at the party
with decided in their infinite wisdom at
half past six in the morning after both
of us having a rohypnol to phone the
then head of the showbiz column in the
Sun and talent that I left take that
so another celebrity yeah kind of yeah
and I desperately didn't want him to do
that but he was like a peer of mine and
somebody that I was kind of beholden to
and looked up to and I'm a dramatic
people pleaser too so I knew that this
was the worst thing that he could do for
me and why did he have the telephone
number to the showbiz editor after 6:00
in the morning any Sun as well for the
Sun after a roofie laughter yeah after
roofie and and so it was but I can't
change that now but yeah at the time
that was a difficult one to swallow the
roofie and then I got cottonmouth
yeah but then also when you go there is
everyone relaxed they're like no you
know what I mean by this like so
obviously we see the public side of Noma
Campbell we see the public side of all
those people that you listed is that
very different environment when is just
you guys going away together like is
that aside that we wouldn't necessarily
save all the celebrities and the same
for you and then the follow-up questions
that is would they then know that you
had an alcohol problem it was the 90s
everyone had an alcohol problem and a
cocaine problem and maybe they did or
maybe they didn't you know some people's
got out of hand and some people's didn't
I'm surrounded by a lot of people that
can handle their drugs you know I'm not
talking about my wife but my you know
there's a lot of people that I just do
that yeah there's a lot of people that I
know that aren't like me you know it's
like what is it 5% of the population or
maybe more than I will have a drink and
drug problem I'm one of the five percent
it doesn't necessarily mean that
everybody that took cocaine needs to go
to Alcoholics Anonymous or
Narcotics Anonymous or goes to rehab you
know some people are gonna get burnt
I got burned so did you feel relaxed not
a moment though among the celebs among
the slaves I knew when you met David
Beckham there's not a first knew we're
gonna get you out of son watching a few
clips here and I could tell you fellas
[__] me yeah he was they having a
birthday party with Pasha Nala and he
had his long blonde hair in a ponytail
at the button I could tell you thought I
could see it it was written all over
your body language of this is [__]
ridiculous isn't it it was so over the
top and all the friends that's me that's
how I am when I meet people you know and
especially I don't know Dave is sort of
is unique as well you know there's an
hmm there's an aura that follows him
around and then all of a sudden you're
in but I cry though after you know yeah
but I could be like that with the third
division footballer right yeah you know
is like whoever that is guide that place
four months but you play for Mansfield
do you yeah yeah how many games but we
even with David Beckham it's even more
multiplied you've met and before this
obviously with you you should be
comfortable at that point is this more
down to what you were talking about to
me about the acrophobia stuff whether
it's just checking agra phobia and
social awkwardness and you know because
i also fill gaps where you know with
stuff that I don't really I'm grabbing
at things it's a bar fight again and
I'll just like fill a gap with something
I've just said that I don't mean it's
all like mean the opposite of what I've
just said but now I can't back out of
that and explain to you what's going on
in my head yeah I'm I'm awkward I feel
awkward I'd like you to be different
yeah and with David Beckham it's you
know soccer I saw him I saw him I like
seven seven weeks ago in Los Angeles he
was on the beach
all right me and then I think of all the
things I can say to him and I try to get
into conversation and I'm like love you
got back out there back away out sort of
like that without breaking vision yes so
we need a man walk out backwards no but
you're why was he hanging understand
because it's like you've been around
these people for years you should be
like you know it's all [__] you've
also earned your place at the table it's
your way you're solidified as one of the
most famous people in this country is
like I don't know you say fine though
I'm a fan yeah you know I'm a fan I'm a
fan of your podcast it's just like when
when you to walk in I'm like it's just
seen you all summer how amazing is that
and you know still still as this podcast
goes on its dissipate in but it might
come back up where I'm like oh yeah I
remember and you said about you that
I've been using about them women that
you shagged oh you know etc etc so I'm
still a fan I'm still human
I still take in television the way that
other people take in TV I still watch
films the way other people watch films
not like slightly part of the must so
weird having to analyze yourself like
this like you beginning some sort of
weird
is it it's I think it's a very natural
reaction to the way that celebrity is
and a lot of people are very good at
just playing it off so that list of
people that you had were incredible
people that just playing the celebrity
game and it seems that actually a lot of
the things that seem like shortcuts
which are being you know extremely
gregarious but in just the right amount
is not where your strength lies but your
strengths are elsewhere and that's why
you're in that circle so you're not a
typical celebrity I don't know what
typical celebrity is or what people
think maybe the archetypal celebrity
what people create this vision in their
mind of how a celebrity should act you
don't act necessarily in that way but
that's not a conscious thing not many
not many have seen extremely conscious
they come across a superclass
I know it's Susan you dog it but do they
oh who does well generally when you
watch an anime for example you come
across that way on Graham Norton when
you're getting up and you're meeting
Elton John and
no no luck you look like you're peeing
doing it yeah but I can't I feel
comfortable around him no you must
because yeah what a double pistol this
is I was watching when you're meeting a
queen but yeah how did you know what the
double kiss because without them I'm not
sure if I'm gunning for a handshake a
hooker - look why in case I had to do it
show biz in it love no you know and I
also know out and from back in the day
yeah you know my scene
yeah the crop the grind yeah yeah so
back windows reg though innit yeah but
sort of what your soon as you've picked
up on those rabbits I've hope you worked
in celebrity circles no but then you're
also saying but still you struggle like
Graham Norton I can be [__] myself
about Graham norm for weeks before it so
I put working at Graham Norton I know
exactly what I'm gonna say there's a
book about that as well as yeah I know I
know exactly what I say I know what
stories I'm gonna do and hopefully these
stories will be entertaining and they'll
hit home and I can be gregarious
hopefully charming if not be funny
follow up on one of those stories oh
yeah yeah yeah but someone in the park
yeah yeah oh right yeah say yeah I can't
follow you on that I'll tell you why
afterwards yeah so yeah but I can do it
in I can do an impression of some I want
to make good TV you want to make good
content you know and you do you know so
I'm the same on television
I want a what's he gonna do next moment
I want to be entertained and I feel as
though it's my duty and sometimes I get
it right and sometimes I get it wrong
and sometimes I get into trouble with
people like the time when you told the
story of the cleaner yeah
was that a similar moment - I need to
fill this gap story was no it's a story
do you know the cleaner story no I'll
take the cleanest story okay so no it's
not so I I know that I've amassed
together quite a lot of stories I'm 43
good quite stories quite a lot of
interesting things have happened to me
yeah and I wouldn't mind putting
together a kind of one-man show maybe
starting at the Edinburgh Fringe or
something and I just tell myself Tyson
does that yes exactly so I was with this
in mind
I went on Graham Norton and I thought
okay so I've got the ability to tell
these stories they translate well they
seem to go down well okay well if I'm
going to do this one-man show in the
future I'll come out fighting I told
this story about this time that I was
renting a castle in who runs the castles
yeah I was renting a castle somewhere I
won't give it out where it was and it
had this enormous room in it which was
my bedroom at the time and I went to
sleep and I woke up and you know as it
is when you wake up you're not fully
awake and the most relaxing times were
you sort of like you don't really know
where you are and I'm sort of in and out
of consciousness and I'm like it's a
suite it feels as though somebody's got
a feather duster and they're cleaning
the room I'm gone nobody should be in my
room
how do they get in my room and while
they're cleaning with the further duster
and I opened my eyes and there was a
lady there of indescribable age she
could have been anywhere from between 32
to 62 I'm not quite sure and she had on
this headset with a Walkman and it was a
tape cassette we were well into CDs by
this time and she had salla tape wrapped
around one of her headphones and she was
using this feather duster like this to
clean my bedroom and I look at her and
she looks at me and she says sir have
you got Morning Glory I know and I note
first of all she went she looked at my
underpants on the floor and she went
Calvin Klein's and I went yeah she went
[__] right she said you got Morning
Glory and I went yeah she went oh won't
you off and I went oh good with my
imagination go on then
so she does the deed she does I wish
that was up in the me so she does she
does the deed I close my eyes and think
of England we haven't got a clear enough
of the hotel that remains as we do
actually anyway she says so ermine you
off she goes and that's the that's the
experience that I had that morning huh
that evening I'm with the lady that is
in charge of the house and I said do you
know the lady that came into my bedroom
to clean my bedroom this morning she was
a bit strange and she said we don't so a
stranger had walked in broke in through
their hands and came upstairs and did
the deed and left because she was a
father yeah yeah yeah yeah but then I'm
telling this story to my band years
later I'm telling this story to my band
like 15 years and my mate in the band
goes from the pub she said she did that
but nobody believed her so Maureen for
the pub's obviously been telling people
have you got a bit of an injury nuts you
see the electricity between us that was
my Maureen or I've actually got a bit of
a [__] to see about a cleaner all right
okay but you say him right a hotel
cleaner in particular because I do I
used to do lords or Tolls you're right
and I got a bit clean that horn yes
somebody said to me the way to
differentiate between what's weird and
not it's fantasizing about shagging the
maid he's not weird right shagging the
maid is weird
mmm that's what I've been told I don't
know where you sit on that I mean are
definitely usually sit on that yeah
cheese if the opportunity arises I'll be
good no matter the age but the thing I
think you you because it's sort of like
the idea that it's random and it's sort
of just happen in that way I would like
that right driven by especially if it
was because it I would like it more sure
it was because she was a fan as well
that would actually do it for me more
right going back to the social weirdness
think what I've been doing is employing
a tactic just recently it's like if I'm
a restaurant or whatever and I'm with a
group of people that I've never met
before I actually think about you guys
this is I know this is weird okay but I
actually think I'm doing a podcast
ringing and I've got to keep the
conversation going so far that's that
tactic that I've employed has worked for
me that's what a meme it's just he's a
car salesman right and he always thinks
when he's talking to someone he has to
be like confident and he goes I just
think what would you add right and what
would Brian take basically is this sort
of energy it's working I guess I don't
bump into many people that have got the
same sort of thing as me I don't mean
many people that go actually I feel the
same way though if I'm in a social
situation that I get drained because
I'll just be completely drained and then
I'll go I'm and switch the TV on and
I'll be sort of as you're performing
within the within the chart yeah yeah
well I'm trying to you know trying to
appear normal and interested and quite
often I am a little sick as well and you
feel like you have to live up to this
Robbie Williams car no I I just want to
I just want to suck see I just want to
beat this thing that I've got that seems
to find out the whirlwind there's a
story in my hometown that you walked
into a local Indian restaurant and
bought a from a meal didn't happen but
I'll take you
fair enough right story that's quite
upsetting then there's a lot of people
tell that story whenever people go to
this no not was [__] bullying and
that was [__] and in Tibetan yeah
there's a kohai street yeah manziel's
bare anyways so any Newcastle stories
yes I've got a Newcastle story come yeah
Maureen appear to be you might know this
story so don't don't trip over the
punchline
that's a Bobby Robson story so Bobby
Robson is doing a book signing and fella
comes up to him and it's like forgive me
for doing the accent I Bobbi yep you've
been here very edges up but you've
you've signed a lord right good
that's pretty disagree you've said let's
better than Lawrence's which is more
like Jamaican right you sent a load
right number because I saw hundreds of
sign hundreds and he gets in he writes
it down Gibbs in the book guys on his
way home and he's on the bus and he
opens it and it says to Timmy
love Bobby hundreds because I Bobby
Robson was just getting on a bit
yeah and he was like famous for his he
used to call all the players by like the
wrong name yes which also joke he needed
that as well
I'm a mobian Johan kebab yeah young
kabob that was the that way down really
well the Joe Kinnear one yeah unless
that so New Castle is for sale
hey not fancy by him would well if any
somebody if anything happens it sort of
has to be in a Port Vale kind of
direction yeah but which direction will
you know buying Port Vale and but I
don't live in this country very often
how they based but I'm kind of find
myself in a position where you kind of
like Paul can I put my foot down on this
thing what happens if I just make it go
fast and I'm like can I can I buy a
football club and and my people are like
yeah why not and you know what are the
covering people because I'm not gonna
fall I want people if we can have a lot
of people you've got some people we've
got I've got some people but I want more
people to sometimes you sometimes you
treat your equals as they if they are
your people I do yeah we text me the day
of most days we do the weekend show and
he goes can I have a full English
breakfast when I arrive Liam night what
to you yeah great great I'm just certain
everything else alot what I do is not
the question is there always a full
English breakfast there when you ask
every time they Wow
he's only you are the reasonable one but
he's he's a the thing is with Lauren she
does a lot don't you me
Lawrence's creative from in front of the
camera bit of everything general I mean
anyway so I've just found out all the
clubs that are for sale
mmm-hmm is there like a record of that
yeah the kind of like a list through of
hits that you can basically you wanna go
for this yeah yeah I'm
I'm not I'm not going to do it because
if I should be doing that anything it
should be with poor veil but also you
know it's like people are not gonna take
nicely to me by Newcastle if I could be
like sort of director of football be my
I would tell you I mean Jesus I mean I
think it's like New Castle's everybody's
second very much fond of Newcastle again
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do it
because it'd be an absolute nightmare of
people would hate me but there is a bit
of me that goes I could do that I could
manage that Club that's how mentor my
life is yeah you know and at some point
I had a actually I really only goes all
the way there in a just Texel Martine
Robbie Williams chefs currently making
my lunch just how great your lunch we're
very helpful here really so okay I'd be
in great shape if I had the young lady
the chef yeah that's what that's what
I'm doing I'm doing I've got no excuses
with us I'm doing plant-based stuff what
does that mean why have you why have you
move towards that
what have I moved towards that because
suppose I've got really ill this year
and I watched a documentary called what
the health you have you seen it
everyone's seen that it's a good they
avoid anything sort of vegan or a food
base because enough it makes you not
want to eat what you like well I'm also
aware just before the internet jumps in
and batters me over the head with the
debunking of what the health I'm also
aware of that too but it kind of made
sense to me he's like show me how you
know meat was processed the the way that
they're looked after or not looked after
the hormones the steroids the did it and
I'm like well yeah I get that and then
if I eat this it's more healthy for you
and this year more than ever I've just
needed to give myself a little bit of
space with looking after myself so I've
started to be plant-based I'm not vegan
I said I erroneously said vegan on an
Instagram thing that I did and the
internet jumped down my throat yeah cuz
I'm not a vegan I got the terminology
wrong sorry guys that's
how the day was bloody lovely yeah still
I'm still at the weekends you know I'm a
bêlit the weekends it's awful just a
different type of doublet but I feel
better and I don't mean I I feel
superior because I'm not adding to the
killing of animals I just feel better
because they're gonna die anyway lighter
yeah anyway what a brilliant response
they cannot die any lot of you know
someone else so that you don't just died
yes you should start a farm ball ditch
these have just died while they
pensioners where we said given them
sponge baths yeah would you like a cup
of tea anagram justly you don't have to
give a pensioner at first of all cows
can't collect a pension second of all it
would be unusual to sponge bath a cow
you always jump in spoil thing I'm
saying is let's avoid the sponge baths
why are you sponge barking a cow
that's what pensioners generally good
right even the cow ones I'll tell you
what I put your coward blood you love us
but who doesn't love a sponge well sure
are you saying you Lee would love a
sponge bath with Paul McCartney love
this much man so I'm told
yeah yeah expensive yeah so when you
have you met Paul McCartney is there
anyone you have a milk yes yes have you
met all the living leads were you more
starstruck
well will you met well with Paul
McCartney myself agent was so bad we
were doing the same TV show this was I
think like 97 or something and it was a
reboot of an old TV show called the tube
have you heard of the tube those are
late 70s early 80s and they were
rebooting it and I was supposed to be
going up to sing with Paul McCartney
what much song probably hate you to
something I got to end the show and I
just thought of myself because it was
really bad that man that legend
shouldn't be on stage with me and he
just doesn't know that he shouldn't be
on stage with me I'm going to put him
out of his misery
and not sink back so I left the but I
think I thought I'd love to know saying
hey
or grave I'm not gonna do that but I
just thought he shouldn't be on stage
and we shouldn't it was that I decided
really thinking that way anyway he
introduced me on stage and since then I
think he he was thinking that I dissed
him wait so he introduced you and then
you didn't come out yes so it looks more
he was really trolling the crowd yeah
but but since then I think he's a bit
suspicious of me yeah maybe
yeah wrongly but let's hope he hears the
story yeah Paul I didn't mean it sorry I
hated myself and I wanted to sing with
you I just thought you shouldn't do
because you didn't know who I was
yeah do you think he could have done
justice so let me entertain you or not
Let Me Entertain You doesn't he really
good yeah yeah haleh's gone and heavens
here there's nothing left you defeated
shake your ass come over here now see
well thank you he done that before yeah
yeah um so who have you been starstruck
by I mean Paul McCartney you met Paul
McCartney though on that Paul McCartney
yeah but I didn't drop a district that
would that would really have thanked
Paul McCartney by Robbie Williams can
you remember when 50 cent did is the was
the art of robbing yeah the roller did
aidid every single big rubber on one
truck and basically said how he was
gonna rob them all yeah I think the time
has gone for me but that was something
that I could have done in the late 90s
who did that I think was Kendrick
Kendrick did something similar and it
wasn't quite as good as they say there's
an M&A there's the record where it's
Drake mm Andre 3000 and Kanye West and
all those and Eminem's the last person
apparently all of us are laced with
disses if you other people on that track
they who have been overwhelmed with
Alton you know yeah like like the first
time hanging around with the mover at
Gianni Versace's house on Lake Como in
Italy and we just arrived this huge
mansion on a life and they even just
heard about its blow me mind yeah it
blew my mind and there was like
cavalcade of just the most chic black
cars you know you know you're talking
about that thought yeah when I come into
this house that's how I feel in this
house like I'm walking on amidst a
lovely house the kitchens being um in my
entire flat Wow I've seen it on skype so
anyway I'm with you know Gianni Versace
and Donatella Versace and Joan Eva
Gianni Versace's come open up some jeans
and so that's actually literal by the
way he's asking for cheese ya know jeans
jeans so then I walk out and it's just
me and out John and we just shooting the
[__] yeah what did he also when you meet
each other do you know do you sort of go
it's me Robbie or do you go obviously
not not at that time because I was like
18 year old Robbie and I just shoot in
the shear and we're walking around this
garden that overlooks this beautiful
lake and at one point a just like a
matrix moment where it just goes your
without John and I went out and John out
the middle of nowhere it was like we
were just shooting the [__] then all of
a sudden I just went you're out of sight
yeah yeah it must have been the biggest
[__] moment of his day but yes of
course I have a kind of up those moments
all the time but that was like an
overwhelming thing you know situations
that you find yourself being what's he
like just for in small talk what does he
talk about I mean like he likes football
doesn't you know what what fedora yeah
he likes football he also loves music
and you know great is an incredible
writer and you sort of talk about things
that are going on in your life you talk
about family you talk about
relationships that you have and you talk
about things that going on in your
career and where you find yourself yeah
because he was in that moment 20 years
ago in the similar sort of moment so you
know they're just people on the
celebrities that's what that's what I'm
starting to learn but yeah
yeah even Chania you know as crazy as
cognac how do you make kanye west that
means yes I have met Kanye West and Kim
really yeah and you came to what Kim's
arse like in person that's big really
yes big love big lovely asked relatively
and he just said I would like fan of
your work which was very sweet
yeah that was it I he might have got me
mixed up with somebody about it
he has been Williams yeah yeah okay what
was you you were great and miss
Doubtfire yeah yeah I've got a million
times yes so Jumanji met Kanye when I
think of Elton Lord one thing that
kosumi heard though is the yes
celebrities and then just being known
yeah because I always ask well a lot of
the time I ask you is the biggest
sticker that you've met all right so who
is the biggest dick code that you Tim
Roth anyway no so it's prepared I think
he owns Blackburn you know about Tim
Roth in am it but what the the amazing
thing is the [__] really stand out
right you know it's not the kind of it's
not the what do you mean by start out
with it could work well you could
because you think they're celebrities
before you become one and become
ingratiate it and know the great and
good you think that they're gonna have
an ego they're gonna be pompous or
there's got to be an edge to them and
I'm pleased to announce that most most
people 98 percent than people that I've
ever met have been lovely and charming
and affable and nice but the ones that
aren't stick out and Tim Roth was a
decade what is he famous for he was in
he was in a film Reservoir Dogs saw back
in the day and he was also in Pulp
Fiction and we were just at a bar and he
sticks out as being the the top what did
he do Lord of make you feel such a bad
first impression again okay so I was a
big fan of Reservoir Dogs and a big fan
of Pulp Fiction and there was Tim Roth
so he's a bit of a here order is a he
was a know many heroes yeah
a hero I think you didn't really well to
that once ya know easy he was a hero
he's just on a prior to campaign and he
look great in the prior to campaign and
he's do and I love those films so I was
kind of like touching the forelock
meeting him I never should be telling
this story
forget him [__] him so we're at the
Groucho Club and I go up i mr. Roffe
it's a pleasure to meet you lovely films
so you've just done the prior to
campaign it's amazing so who are you I
mean my name's Robbie what do you do I'm
in a band I was in a band called take
that I'm not oh yeah I've heard of them
really dismissive incredibly dismissive
and then was dismissive of the whole
room
I was playing snooker with
what's-his-name Keith Allen and Stephen
Fry and it was like really just like wow
this is I've never experienced this
before he goes over to speak to my
girlfriend at the time and he turned to
me and he said how did you get a
girlfriend like this and I undid my pool
cue went over to him put it up to his
face and I said I know how it feels to
be insecure I'm really insecure myself
but the next words that come out of your
mouth better be [__] nice I'm gonna
wrap this [__] book around your head
and he left so that's my Tim Roth story
and then the reservoir dogs' music sigh
playing your ostrich yeah decision-maker
the various so yeah so there was a
resemblance that's lasted that's that in
the book Chris he's now it's in the next
one yeah have you met a celebrity that's
pitched you off a few YouTube doing piss
me off I mean no I think the thing is
with me is celebrity uh non-celebrity
people are usually a bit like probably
want to be nicer that guy he makes up in
Hitler's or something they get this
impression of hours so most people are
nice there was regardless bit
standoffish have you then
try thinker of mebut I didn't really
like I've been surprised the other way
when people have been overly nice yeah
sure I think there's been a real [__]
know there was a there was some from The
Only Way Is Essex who was really funny
who thought everyone watched the show
and then he was talking to me as if I
knew who these people were and I never
bother oh no no notice the odds I love
mark oh yeah and I felt a bit sorry for
him cuz he went you know I've been
hanging out at mark and I'm sorry who's
Mark Moore and I was just a runner and
now I'm sorry who's mark and he went
mark from the show yeah from the show I
love our lovely I felt really sorry for
him do you know it wasn't an [__] you
just didn't know he was doing - no I
mean because loo seemed nice you both
often talk about like loose women loose
women really pissed me off and I was a
little ii am yeah we show it basically a
noise that we feel like we should be
getting their budgets yeah I mean it's
incredible - it's incredible and
entertaining to watch but i'll and i
always think might yeah
stick it to ever you want to stay
jealousy really yeah exactly
I'm also watching going wait till you
find out that these are all just people
and they're just people that doing this
for me particularly is I look at them
and I think they're just they're just
casualties in the war like they did in
it and it's just good necessary here's
how much you influence mistake right and
this I told you this before the podcast
here's how much you influenced me soccer
am used to be my favorite TV show and
will you in with some of that crowd
because they were like really not all at
that time he was a bit big boy for them
you know do you think they thought they
were in with you there was that like
soccer a time when it was like no soccer
am not soccer
no I know but there's no soccer am not
know I didn't hang out with them but it
was my favorite TV show right anyway so
it has declined but it's still held its
ground but when you were sort of like
sagging it off I was like yeah I'm not
gonna
so I haven't watch soccer a.m. again
until last night when I put it on and it
was like the best bits of the week and
I'm like I'm gone this is still got some
legs no it hasn't me the thing is it
died the reason it is where it is is
because it's the only [__] show that
skya put like if you had on sky1
a show made by all those [__] husbands
no offense I mean they're probably
lovely people but husband had minor
Lawrence issue in coral we would [__]
annihilate them but it's because they're
getting all of the money in order we're
annihilate them anyway we're getting
better views than them anyway I think on
me on [__] beat them on the old chart I
think you're right lovely guys what an
aisle eight them and I would watch that
TV show they're lovely guys though
behind your scenes yeah I met them all
they all seem like nice guys I guess
it's not it's not impersonal this is
strictly business
I mean I'm putting them out of business
in our industry there is that line of
like that blurred lines so in a way I am
sure Gary Bowl oh is that what it is
it's soccer am is is Brian yeah I just
want songs recently the thing is this
this channel this this company they're
really out of date you know I mean and
one thing in entertainment is you've got
to move with the times and they haven't
done and we are and now what they try to
do is claw a bit but buy so much loose
women don't you
loose women I think that's more
Lawrence's issue than mine I'll let you
take that on Lawrence because there's
Vice Sun there quite a bit yeah I I
think the vibes a little bit off it's a
lot of it is or to be honest I'm not
washing quite while maybe it's
definitely a wife on it but when it was
back in the day when it first started
was much more like
yeah so my husband's a [__] anyway
here's a guest right and I didn't really
like that not did it not entertain you
so the one bit that I've been offended
by in the past are a point will you
trick it a little bit right where one
woman basically said yeah stop [__]
me husband awhile ago and then they
literally wield the husband out the day
off
to get his opinion on how it feels to be
sexless and it's like some things like
you shouldn't I felt that the man was
being completely humiliated by his wife
saying I just want to [__] him anymore
yeah I get what you're saying the thing
that I'm thinking it's like when I was
talking about the bar fight yeah
everybody's in their own little bar
fight and you know she's on loose women
she probably isn't thinking things
through in front of several million
people her down the lens and she's
thinking of things that she can pull and
talk about she talked about that and
then her husband got in trouble at work
I think is what happened probably
because he wasn't getting a shot and
then he was it was mortified and he was
embarrassed and then you as you as you
do when you're in that situation you
feel as though you've gotta come and
have your say so I reckon he was just
come in to have it so but yeah I was
embarrassed just feel a bit like and I'm
sure I had men a bit I'm not sure as
well and that that's one thing that gets
it because this is the new generation of
women who they take empowerment over the
line of hit and Men and I'm all for
women being like girl power that's cool
whatever right and if it was the other
way around etc but it wouldn't happen
the other way around we're sort of held
away online you know me that's what I'm
trying to do a little bit but I think
they take it too far and another thing
is they're they don't even let you speak
I mean your if your last interview or
name it was enough so it shambles in my
opinion because I could see and it's
like he's the [__] guest you get that
yeah like I'm a tough [__] who isn't
even media trained you literally talking
every the rule number one you are show
up a second yes let the celebrity
[__] talk me an hour later it's just
I thought I me outside of that show
being on it or not I just and my wife
I've always been entertained by it and
and there's nothing else on at that time
in the day I'm sorry literally sit there
and have that wash over me and have my
judgments no it's got its place loose
women as opposed to around which is gone
by the wayside yes it's a signature
that's loose women has got its place I
don't dispute
okay so you're not given the chance to
do soccer Am's rival TV show but you are
given the chance to do loose men on the
BBC or channel 4 do you do it I mean how
much other pen because if it's good
money yes in a test do you do you think
there's I mean no web we're far from
artistic integrity meter but do you
think there's an element of that to it
where a lot of content now feels a bit
lowest-common-denominator and it fits so
soccer am to me still feels very much
like they're still going for the men
that they did when Lovejoy was on it Tim
Lovejoy not the Lovejoy yeah
the detective yeah it's a great format
my dad loves it I think he thinks for
himself is a bit of a Lovejoy type you
know again middle-aged men love watching
that show cuz they're like I can be that
middle-aged man right you know Inc it's
a great show and then loose women maybe
felt when I watched it when it first
came on a bit wrong I don't know I you
know I'm not you can't comment I'm not
here to come and fight the corner for
loose women it was more jovial than
anything because I know that you you
knew that I was coming on for the the
podcast and I was watching one of your
podcasts
actually not all of them I was in like a
hotel in baden-baden wherever that is
and I would just pace myself one thing I
do want to talk about is songwriting can
we talk a little bit about that because
you were hidden away and take that then
you finally go on your own journey and
get to make your own songs and your song
of your career comes angels massive
massive song the biggest song someone
simply wrote that and there's a video on
YouTube where this guy who explains
exactly how it you sent us the video
yourself explains exactly how your and
you you watching this
like totally believe it like he's so
believable mercy very - it's not
conspiracy right now it actually
happened mm-hmm what but I'll tell you
the whole story after about a cigarette
okay Wow okay yeah after these messages
okay we've got a list I know so we can
cut there were commercial break the same
as these women he's going outside and
going yeah honey they slacked off even
to my face welcome back next up Robbie
Williams tells us all about his
co-written song angels co-written song
yeah yeah cuz I left it on a bit of a
cliffhanger there yeah actually because
you said it was it conspiracy theory in
our city actually did happen yeah not
that somebody co-wrote angels with me
there's a guy in Ireland that I knew for
a short period of time in between hunks
mate just held no man in between take
that and my solo career and how angels
came about was I was in my sister's back
garden and I thought that I should at
least attempt to write a song and I knew
that I could write their eggs because
I've done a bit in the past so I sat
down right I sitting away does an angel
contemplate my fave do they know the
places where we go and the gray and old
and you know it took me an hour to write
a couple of verses and my sister had a
poem that she'd written and one of the
lines was and as the feeling grows she
breathes flesh to my bones and I'm like
right I'm Nick in that so if anybody
co-wrote the song it was my sister
anyway so to see the royalties though I
think we all know she's been well taken
care of
yeah well yeah in in this period in time
I go out to Ireland and I go on the piss
and I get very friendly with somebody
very very quickly there's a whole
extravaganza that goes on with this
story might save it for the film one day
but I'll just be brief and keep it
simple and I'm back at his house and
he's playing me this song that he's
written and it's called horny boy
don't do it it's about this girl that
commits suicide and I'm like will you be
you you write songs we should write a
song together I've got idea for this
song them I hire a studio in Temple Bar
in Dublin and we go in the studio and
was such a mess because we're so Mullard
which is absolutely completely in this
time period while I mean Island one day
I drunk 23 pints of Guinness I got very
early and went all the way through the
day and after twenty three pints of
Guinness yeah I don't know if you've
ever drank yourself sober everything
just saw where's you think you're sober
but you're not really but it feels that
you are doesn't it just wears off
doesn't come out of the vortex and is in
a different place anyway so we're in the
studio we can't quite get it together
because I don't really know what I'm
doing
we're drunk and it doesn't happen but
I've got this sort of song idea that
I've got and angels used to go in its
first incarnation was a vinegar I'm
loving angels and angels and angels whoa
angels instead and that was the chorus
bit of a crap chorus anyway so we're in
the studio and we put something down and
I realize it's not working so we beat a
hasty retreat and went to the pub and a
few things went on with me and this guy
while I was there and a left Island and
my mum is in such a bad mood with me
because I went to Ireland with her and
then she never saw me because I was
always in the park and I was always with
this guy mmm so she's furious because
I'm in the middle of it I'm worried
about because I'm in the middle of a
heavy drinking problem and we are in
stoke-on-trent one evening back at my
mom's house and I need to go somewhere
my mom's driving me and I see this guy
from Island he's in Stoke and he's
looking through the window of somebody's
house and he's on
his way to my house and I said mom
that's that's the guy and we should go
back to ask because it'll be at the
house any minute now and she said well
he's not staying here because she was
furious he was the man that was sort of
leading me astray but I was you know we
were leaving each other astray and there
was a knock at the door and I opens it
and I I want to greet him and bring him
in and at least give him the bed for the
night but I'm also in trouble with my
mom
so I said Raymond what what are you
doing I thought you'd be pleased to see
me I don't know well may you can't stay
here it's just weird that you're turning
up out of the blue and I gave him a
couple of hundred quid and said I think
it was a couple hundred quid and go get
yourself a better breakfast and go back
to Ireland so he was downhearted and off
he left I then go to a meat guy chambers
who's my songwriting partner and the
first day I said well I've got this idea
for this song and I sing him the song
and it's angels and then he hits a chord
and I go and through it oh she offers me
protection and it sort of writes itself
and we got now the fully formed version
of angels and I knew we got something
really special and I got so ill the
minute would finish Ryan it there was
like a download of something that
happened and he took himself off the bed
and I just wandered the streets back
from his house in wherever it was and
wandered Oh sort of like with this tape
in my hand and I've got in this cab and
I went mate just played it put it on and
he played angels and he said that's
number one that is I knew we had
something special
anyway I release my first album and
because this is this is like a myth that
goes around in fact Bono used to tell
this story I because okay I was with
Bono and he told me about this story the
uniqueness song from this busker and I'm
like that didn't happen why is bono
telling that because he'd heard it he'd
heard folklore about this Irish busker
that I'd happen to bump into and stole
I'll check in as facts before you smoke
listen Garrity if it's if it's a good
story you know I'll tell it you know
it's in favor of an Irish Bosco I'm sure
he'll tell it I'm the same if I hear a
good story and it's just you've got to
tell somebody you gotta tell somebody it
doesn't happen to be true anyway so the
album gets released and then I get a
letter from a lawyer in Ireland and my
client mr. Raymond Heffron has not only
wrote all before I died I think he said
and he's also written well Oh angels but
he's also written all before I die
two great songs well thank you very much
yeah anyway so I wrote all before I die
in Miami Latino guy can't remember his
name what's his name Chris Desmond
Charles song writer he wrote livin on a
prayer yeah yeah incredibly talented so
this was the what we were left with do
you mean that wasn't Bon Jovi that Bon
Jovi also had a hand living [__]
laughter anyway so this is what was
gonna happen it was all down to if he
said she said or he said he said now we
could have gone to court and it would
have all been down to weather
what what what way the gorge wakes up
that day bed and goes I believe this guy
and he's going to get the publishing you
know so we were then left with it like a
settling out a court sort of thing
because we couldn't have that happen
yeah you know because who believes who
so I gave him some money and he went
away but in subsequent documentaries
about me he plays this tape that he's
got with me singing he never gets the
chorus cuz there's no chorus but he also
said what happened was his him and his
missus
she was pregnant and then she lost the
baby right and when it's stillborn this
term for in Ireland you lose an angel
and he says he's in a documentary I
assume that yeah it's all believable and
he sits down and he said and so I wrote
the lyrics to angels underneath this
statue in France and I'm like okay I'll
watch that back and I'm like well he's
not gonna believe that it's got the sob
story and everything yeah and also you
know it's incredibly believable but look
at the career he's had afterwards
thought he's gone on a hit hit after hit
up there nobody believed him is the
thing and I'm like up is telling this
story is somebody in the past and I was
like a new songwriter now and II write
songs and they're not gonna be very good
and I press play and in fact that's
actually no sounds that's a good song
yeah actually a good song it's a good
song yeah he is it's talented but the
thing is you know it's like on the
Wikipedia page it says like co-written
by Raymond Heffron and if you ever
remove his name somebody puts it back up
straightaway so there's this myth going
around that angels there's a piss you
off
yeah pisses me off yeah pisses me off
and I wrote it your sisters probably not
in the credits my sister's not the crazy
colleagues after but it's unjust and
it's unfair and it's my biggest song and
you know and I'm also became the
corporate entity that is Robbie Williams
and of course this person rode roughshod
over somebody's career and stole this
song and absolutely didn't how does it
feel when people are always trying to
take credit for all the things you've
achieved it doesn't happen very often
I've seen your mother just that he's a
little [__] I was like I gave it was I
met him he was basically when you were
saying you know I was good and that's
why you picked me and he was put in
office if I had never picked me you
wouldn't be where you are today and
stuff like that so that there are people
out there who do that surely yeah but
nothing that's raised its head you know
the 20-something years so it's it's not
something that I passed judgment on you
I'm normally taking credit for
else's work is the songwriting process
normally quiet not easy for you but do
you find it something's quite natural
not anymore
I found it ready you know there was a
lot to write about in the early days my
diary was interesting and you know
that's why this like the ways this
albums the first to the most amazing
with all the [__] and all this [__] in
the pain of the high octane and the
dreams and the naivety and Beatles and
the Beatles and you kind of have a lot
to write about and then even like right
I was like Eminem and you see the fire
dims as they get older yeah but it
doesn't with him to see what he comes
back with something really real but I
think after was a recovery when we did
quite a few bangers on that one book I
just wanted to I just wanted to get oh I
can do this I can sing melodies and I
can write lyrics okay I just wanted to
get better and better and better and I
was never happy with what I just done
and I always thought that there was I
was working towards the what's it called
the Opus yeah the the the main body of
work that will become your Opus what's
the world therapist deus or something
right where you're basically chasing
artists Magnus and you're basically
chasing that yeah anyway it didn't
happen so hey you know it's like oh I
wrote some I wrote some great so you're
great this is pretty [__] good thank
you very much and it's what's your
favorite Robbie Williams album The
Greatest Hits yes it's great what is not
even office that's know that Alan
Partridge where he doesn't know anything
about the Beatles and then he goes watch
your head and Abbey Road why don't say
Bethel anyway so I've done 12 albums and
you said got the enjoyment of me in them
not as much not as much anymore I find
that you know when your careers rolling
and you're at the zeitgeist and
everything's going your way so I playing
a game of pool and you can't miss the
ball and then the oxygen that you need
for that to survive erodes as time goes
on because you know pop is a young
person's think and it
moves away and it moves on and the
oxygen that you need is saturation from
Radio and then when radio decide to not
play you you because there's like loads
of songs that I've had that if it was
anybody else in any other band that kind
of it wouldn't have it wouldn't have
been here wouldn't have been played but
I was just in the pocket you know and
then the oxygen is removed and you're
not saturated anymore and you kind of
like war I've got a family and I've got
kids and also I've got an ego and I
don't want to be yesterday's man and I
want to keep this movie you sort of your
priorities change and whereas before I
was trying anything because I was
experimenting all of a sudden you sort
of like I've got to find a hit from
somewhere and I never thought like that
you know so I'd never thought if I don't
get a hit we all die and that's how it
feels now it's like well if I don't get
a bonafide hit it's the radio is not
going to play me this is not going to
work so then you've you've gone into a
territory that it's different now
because it's like I mean you know you're
not there yep up there are some artists
if it doesn't matter how old they are
and what they look like and anything
like that they're always going to be
people who want to say that Tom Jones
for example is like just homeless people
always turn up to watch him and and you
can you could easily be that guy yeah
but yeah people do come I've got a live
audience and they go there hopefully if
I do a good enough job every time I go
onstage they're gonna stay with me and I
did a good job this summer you know I
did a really good job so that's sort of
taken care of but you want the game to
go on as long as you can yeah you know
you want it you want you don't want to
you don't to take part you want to be
you've sorted because you can how joyous
it feels to have written a song that
then a stadium full of people know all
of the words to and that happens you're
in you're out you're in you're out this
then all of a sudden you release a song
and then oh just a pocket for the people
over there in the big stadium mouths up
sometimes with the newest songs
yeah they don't know them as well yeah
yeah so with the last album is I wrote
80 songs trying to find this gold nugget
they there's a song called I love my
mistake though yeah it's a mistake
because they come to you you and well
if you like generate a hit like easily
didn't want so they just showed in every
single yeah well you know it was a
mistake so sure I should write what I
feel and how I feel but you just want
the game to go on as long as you can
because there's there's a lot of fun
doing promo just as a bit like that in a
way I mean obviously it's you just chase
and that next big guess what I say
earlier on you're always gonna be you're
always gonna be chasing risen the bold
but but I seem to be moving into a
different category of artists now and
the the worst thing that can happen to
me I mean my last albums are platinum
album which is a massive album it's it's
incredible but I didn't get the one hit
to hit three hits and off you go he just
did didn't happen I love my life kind of
made an impulsive big song wasn't it
okay so you know you know love my life
of course okay so that made an impact so
maybe it does still exist but I was
always thinking that you know when your
audience moves away from you or when
people move on it would feel deathly but
it's it's alright you know I still go
out to promote darts to go out to sing
to 1.2 million people this summer I've
got a really incredible career it's just
going in a different way and I've just
got to play my cards right now you know
to keep people interested and to
interest myself you said name I want to
rights I just want to write a
rock-and-roll album do you do you have a
favorite Robbie Williams era like you
have a favorite era version for yourself
your favorite version no were a lot of
in 1978 I was cure four year old yet
what a wonderful person
no not really I'm always writing the
next thing right I'm always writing the
next thing but always searching for the
next thing whatever I've got next I'm
the most passionate about what's done is
done it's gone how do you think that is
to live with because that's a similar
question to what we asked Eddie halls of
life Eddie hall about his wife how
difficult that was to live alongside how
do you think you are to live with in
when you're going through that creative
process not difficult
at all I should go into the studio and I
either come up with one or a don't come
up with one it's not like a deal where
where it doesn't really though we live
in with me generally yeah you'd have to
ask my wife but there's one clip of you
and I've got to admit this right was
when your missus was about to give birth
and I see in that clip
yeah she's dancin roaches in liver to
say but did you see all the other ones I
gathered it was a joke afterwards well
first watched her for hours
what the [__] Robbie Williams doing
these days I was at his really mortified
because we arrived at the hospital and I
drew had bought some really flashy heels
that she was going to be in bed with
Instagram the picture which she did and
he was like everybody's looking at the
picture of the heels that's funny huh we
should do a thing we should do a thing
we did a sketch so then we did a sketch
where to write sky der is up and she's
dancing in front of me and she's really
pregnant and it looks funny and we like
oh look everybody's looking at that it's
funny do you know what we should do next
and then it escalated because I made you
look like a [__] did so then people
start retweeting that one yeah a lot
more so no silly one Texas because we
think we're in a hospital in Los Angeles
and building everybody's getting the
joke and everybody's playing along with
all the first thing no no not at all so
and we like and you know why I should do
now I should dance around you and you
should be really unimpressed and so we
do this whole thing and then Charlie's
born and we have we have a laugh with
the birth of Charlie we just had a laugh
all night making up these sketches and
being silly and then we didn't think
anything about him and then the next day
sort of open up the room where she's
just given birth and the lady comes out
of the next room she said oh I just oh I
just saw you on Good Morning America
like you saw us on what because I'm not
famous in America I was like yeah we see
oh my god the thing that your husband
was doing and I was like there's a
it's not company I stock on down very
well yeah people think that I'm that guy
in Northeast for 47 million people Jesus
via Facebook you that was the impression
that our guys yeah I know and yeah I
mean like I don't know how I don't know
how you spoke because we're gonna do
more of that stuff in the future and
there will be more planned astrology but
III don't know how you signal to people
are actually she's in on the joke this
is a joke
well I watch the side at the bottom
hashtag shows now I know you I watched a
buck on the way down today and I was
like well that's obviously a joke but
the first time I watched it but I but I
wonder because I wonder if you were told
what to think because of the headline in
the newspaper yeah which is which is
what you know it's like the signal is
Lukic Robbie Williams being an absolute
dick to his wife because it went down
like a [__] sandwich you know it's like
there was a lot of joy and then all of a
sudden I lose a woman would have been
right over for you oh yeah polly known
and was like finger wagging and she was
just like how could you do that and I'm
like how could you not see that it was a
gag but I do think the way people type
it up and the newspapers and online it's
like it influences what you think when
we watch it most people won't even watch
the video they'll just sort of go oh he
was made and iPhone yeah yeah I've never
liked him anyway blah blah blah yeah so
this is like there was like a we used to
go to like mum's ink or something online
to look up things my Monsters Inc yeah
it - Kate how do you take care of your
babies and stuff and then they'd be like
forums for Robbie Williams what a nasty
bastard he was I'm like oh oh my god
heartless were you setting up anonymous
accounts going out no I quite like this
here what a yeah millennium yeah this is
a little birthing music yeah ya know if
you've listened to better man haven't
listened to the lyrics good that's the
real Robbie Williams that guy in the
anyway my favorite era I like the one
you did all the rat-pack stuff and that
there's a good one I really like that
which is a very good moment to actually
bring in the man that influenced me into
loving Goa
yeah yeah that was a seamless segue
that's really good it's good dad
my favorite Robby ear I was probably
when you started do the swing stuff and
Sinatra and to be honest I was a little
billing Robby doing that and then but
when you did the show we had a moment
where I was rounded a family friend's
house where me and Isha pause oh did you
get a Robbie Williams DVD for Christmas
yeah and then she asked about six people
in the room and she's like she went you
have not had a Christmas unless you have
this Wow she said this is Christmas shut
up with Sylvia so she pirated your DVDs
yes she absolutely loved you and and she
absolutely loved that DVD and one of the
favorites I think was um where you said
to your mom you know like that was a big
moment for us in the Rwanda this is the
man that's responsible for grow up with
listening to that sort of music who's my
kind of music still is and big fan then
so big fan now and I just love it what's
your favorite Robbie sauce my dad by the
way yeah this is mr. Williams himself
this is mr. Williams senior yes you can
actually take credit for Robbie here
angel
Wow I was there at the conception what's
your favorite song that Robbie does from
that era Oh mr. Bojangles really yes
because I remember him saying - he was a
bit concerned whether you get it right
or wrong this great song it is and he
was done by Sammy Davis
that was something that something did a
great job on it I remember up saying to
me I don't know whether I'll do it
justice or not
well he didn't just do it justice he
knocked it out of the ballpark and it
was great and I got a big kick out yeah
cuz you were doing cool music then and
then out of nowhere you go and do this
sauce of it I was a little bit like yeah
I'm not sure this is the right move when
you pulled it off preed I liked about it
is there's not many people that do what
Rob does the collective move over and I
think you set the precedent them because
he did that swing album a lot of other
people did swing those thereafter than
that came and it started with Rob's on
it and a high selling album I think is
it yeah 8 million copies yeah really
must've on society stuff do you think
that came from her oh yeah my dad yeah
in 1974 yeah one is heat on I wouldn't
phases in 73 the biggest talent show oh
yeah it was then I was doing comedy I
was doing stand-up comedy but he used to
do a song to get off so then I did that
for her forever that's how I earn my
living
and then one night in 1999 I sang that
slide with Rob on the BBC it was called
and I did this song this that's that's
life and suddenly became a senior in
1999 I was doing the holiday comes at
that time but then I was getting phone
calls from television shows will put a
big band in and come sing something with
us so as much as I wanted to be like
Chuck D an easy E I also wanted to be
more calm and wise Tommy Cooper Danny
Kaye Frank Sinatra Dean Martin so I I
was allowed to play with my heroes and I
went to record swing when he went in at
the Capitol studios in Los Angeles where
Sinatra recorded all of his records and
I played with Sinatra's piano player on
one for my begging yeah yeah and you did
you out with Dean Martin did the duet
with Dean Martin too
oh it was absolutely wonderful you can
imagine for me go with my lad into
capital Studios where I've seen it on
the telly have seen Sinatra there
The Beatles recorded that hmm knocking
call all my people I know your son's
there and now my lads there yeah how
good it was like a bit surreal oh it's
brilliant
that's just a big kick I mean I've had
an extension of my entertaining life
because I've done okay I mean I've
survived for a long time big Conway was
the stage name and still is when I work
who but I've just become from being Pete
Kong dad comes on tour with me I've
since our does a song I've seen it on
your vlogs as well yeah I've become
Robbie Williams dad yeah that's retitle
now but you used to be his like known as
his son because he was he was the name
but in store I'll tell you a story right
from the beginning when Rob was very
young and I was doing okay and I was on
the telly and doing radio and Robertson
school and I was divorced from John and
then people used to say to Robert school
you can't be Pete Conway so because your
name Williams yeah so we have to fight
this corner then later when Rob got in
to take that girls saying to me you got
me Robbie Williams dad because your name
pick on me so it happened to me at the
time the story about the time that you
were abroad oh we were we've been
playing golf I was living in nature we
were sitting at the end of a bar here so
he is the bar is the latest toilets here
and I'm sitting on here having tapas and
there's only a few people and it's early
we were other game of golf and this
woman walked past and went into the loo
when she came out she came to me she
said on you Robbie Williams is dad I
said I am yeah she said I thought you as
you know I think so we went to all the
questions and answers she said I've got
a friend over there and she said ended
with a daughter and they're big fans do
you mind if they come over I said no and
I was flipping him over so we carry on
having the toughest and she comes over
to me with a friend and the door transit
the friend said if you're Robbie
Williams his dad who's his favorite
singer it's a quiz I said right no idea
I said I think he's naughty pence I know
he wakes up thinking about in the
morning basically she said you know
Robbie Williams is dad favorite singer
as Elvis Presley I said always it she
said he's got Elvis tattooed on his arm
come weighs a decade and drag this rock
is come with a stick
I'm always a dick at social examine I
went and so mommy's just called you dick
I so don't care so and then when she's
going out so tell me what is it Elvis is
it Elvis I'm quite a big Elvis phone as
well be honest I think he's really by
young men these days I don't think
people realize how good well this was
let me tell you a little story about
what we did we went on the tour to
Australia and that this was the talk
this was a story of the tool when we did
the swing to her and earlier I left my
camera on the plane so where I've been
Perth first day in Australia and I go
into a little shop in Perth run by
little Chinese ladies and I said I need
a new camera that one there she said you
need memory stick and battery I said
okay I saw you put them in for me cuz
I'm hopeless she said I put for you so
she puts him in she says you hear
holiday I said a bit holiday but work
she said what you do I said I think
she'll say what song what song do you
sing I said I sing swingy things she
said I like swing you
she said where you go do that I said the
arena she said you go sing arena I said
yeah I said you know Robbie Williams she
said lobby lobby come / I said love he
came with me last night I'm his dad she
said no your love you dad
no girls all these girls girls girls
claw be done oh really
you have photo and ghosts yes control
all these photos then she says you won't
kiss a lot wrong and I saw him she said
no no no kiss for camera camera case sit
back
gondol wanted papers got a laugh when I
got back and told the lies when I got in
the hotel anyway that's good to say
losses off we have a lot of ups on say
yes it's great it's wonderful one great
opening when you when I came on on one
of the shows this time when you had done
a few songs and I think we're in nois
where we were open its kind of leave you
somewhere and because he just has run
one line of the song and everybody sings
so they all go often it's like the
karaoke session it they all know their
words so he did three or four songs and
then he'll sing and he's up to graph to
get it going so I come on isn't he is my
dad so I walk under dad and he said they
don't know I am really wrapped in the
sentiment what's happening on stage and
and attend to me dad just whisper
something to him any nods back at me and
everybody's wondering what it was he's
on the boards it was on the comments or
Twitter I wonder what he said to his dad
and what I said was much of the day as
soon as we get actually seen it on it's
on somebody recording it if you can
lip-read you can see yeah and they must
have told you what a great night and how
wonderful it's been tonight soon as we
get it brilliant and did you watch smash
today oh yeah oh yes we did with my
today's on that's where we are we'll be
watching it won't be much today we're
watching football tonight here yeah
nice that's what we do yeah no I'm
really I'm really satisfied with what we
got
congratulations yeah hundred percent but
yeah no D how do we add moment by the
way when we were gonna do this podcast
what I knew all the way through the
podcast because I'm a whale that like
seven eight years ago someone not like
really close to was up like lost them
they died and you know when you've gone
through like a really bad time or
whatever musics on the radio and severe
and hits you a lot harder and I'm
wandering on me house [__] angels
comes on and it's it's that song isn't
when you're really emotional next thing
I know I'm just sitting down at the
floor [__] crying me eyes only anyway
I got to say a close friend of mine the
next day and I said I've been last night
I just absolutely lost it
absolutely what happened on 30 angels
was on the radio wasn't it anyway wrong
[__] Robbie Williams and Leslie and
obviously you got in touch via email and
I went I don't know when you'll never
guess who's asked me to be on my podcast
[__] Robbie Williams I'm gonna tell
him for what he did it was and when the
email does you when you're selling that
in the first email you said something or
someone is telling me I need to come on
your podcast and just the way you
wrought though and [__] on that all
this person that story in the one
[__] shivers up my spine yes yes so
me the last question I mean last thing
on say it's thunks forgetting this
through that tough time because
sometimes you just need to cry a [__]
eyes oh I and that song really helped us
and how would you like to be remembered
as we final thing on how you always say
this yeah when did you come up with this
idea
the last I just think we were in Ireland
with this guy but we're writing a script
and and he just said it just gives you a
real good idea of who a person is when
you ask them who they want to be seen us
know I think sometimes when you
I don't place any expectations on that
some people like Alan Shearer I kept it
short and sweet but he says it really
gives you a good window and who he
really is general I mean so I think
that's all I'm trying to do with that
question their precious really no but
it's not it doesn't have to be with
people no it doesn't have to be about
how general public sees you it could be
your family a daughter like any anything
you're not I mean my kids to know that
they are loved and they are safe and
they always have been I want to be I
want to have done a great job there I
want to be a good husband to my wife but
that's about what I don't care because
people talk about oh yeah we're working
with such-and-such and he's building
these gyms and that's going to be as
legacy and he sees as his legacy and
there's a big legacy thing in America
that people talk about yeah well you
know have the happy [__] dead no but
like so for example your legacy in the
eyes of the British public is the
biggest sullen male solo artist in
British music history that is a legacy
whether you want it or not it's there I
mean that will be friend of the podcast
me this is about a fella will get that's
at the end of the conspiracy of course
you can ask that question back I want to
be a good husband I want to be a good
friend I don't want to go
all right they're not sir thanks very
much gentlemen good to see you thank you
no see your own house and letting us use
it yes guys cheers which one we're doing
that con this one here right down there
main barrel hopefully you've enjoyed
this will hopefully try and get them on
again let us know what you thought of it
it's been emotional liked the video
subscribe thanks for watching
we'll say is that I'll see you in the
comment section